Hello everyone.
Hello.
I lost a nap.
Gotcha.
I thought, but the thing is I didn't lose it one time.
I lost it three times in a row today.
Because I was like, I woke up and I was like, I'm so tired.
What if I do one more hour?
What if I, what if I do another hour, baby, let it ride.
Let it ride.
Let's do it again.
Maybe then I won't be I feel like a little boy.
I was like, Mom, Mom, look, I have a little hair on my chin.
Oh, my God.
I think I got the puberty.
Okay.
All right.
So, all right.
I'm good.
I'm good now.
um i had to wake up early today sorry i'm fucking i'm still
in the bahamas right now i close my eyes and i almost see it
i almost see it no by the way there's been i'm not posting a
schedule this week because i was like there's three days i'm
just posting waiting rooms but i'll give you guys a heads up
on like what time i'll be streaming and stuff so it's not
like a total surprise But only people who watch this stream
will know this.
So you guys have like, it's like the, like what is it
called?
The Secret Disney Club, the D, the, the D.
Sorry, you know what?
What's the Secret Disney Club that they have where like you
pay, you pay extra to have an exclusive club?
I don't remember what it was called, but we're like that.
But only people who are watching this stream will know it's
like exclusive for you.
The D Club.
I'm pretty sure it's not the D club.
Guys, what was the secret?
D23.
We're like D23, but we're D24.
Actually, we're D69.
Nice.
Sorry, I'm like, you guys know I have a humor with a teenage
boy.
Wait, no.
Teenage boys, if you talk about the 6-7s, I have a humor of
an 18-year-old boy.
who just got into college.
We're in the D69 club, everybody.
Anyway, so only you guys will know what the schedule is
gonna be like for the next two days.
So tomorrow, it's gonna be afternoon stream.
We're gonna play a horse magnifier.
And then 5 p.m.
or 6 p.m.
We're gonna play Even I forgot my schedule Give me a sec
Very sure to post my schedule Animal Hospital I'm gonna play
Animal Hospital tomorrow So 1230 Horse Magnifier It's about
horses and magnified glass What else do you need to know?
And then on Saturday I'll stream at 5 p.m.
It's on my schedule It's like something I just have it on my
Google Calendar It just says something.
I don't know what that something is, but it's something.
That's a...
Wow, I can't wait for something.
Yeah.
I'm so excited.
All right, so life update.
No dad update because he's still...
still he's he's on his own Bahamas trip right now I know my
dog sitter has been spoiling him like fucking crazy as
someone that's been getting dad up I'm getting my own
personal dad updates but um basically he's getting like
big-ass treats every day like I don't know I can hear this
let's see we're in crunching I am crunching right now look
at that he's cool he's living a fucking life right now this
is like and then yes and I was like oh shit that's a big ass
fucking okay let me I'm gonna okay I'll screenshot okay I'm
gonna screenshot this and you're gonna be like damn that's a
big ass fucking treat and I'm like I know I was like, what?
That's a John ass treat.
I'm going to screenshot this.
And then, but that, this was today.
This is yesterday.
And here this is yesterday.
He got another John ass treat.
That's sorry, that's their TV.
And then he's, here's him playing with his other John ass
treat.
Alright, bro, he's not going to have, he's going to hate
coming back.
He's He's gonna be, where's my daily treat of the day?
He's gonna be like, where's my food?
I was like, here's your meal.
I was like, where's treat?
Where's my pre-meal treat?
My post-meal treat.
My pre-treel, pre-pre-dinner treat.
And then pre-meal treat.
And a midnight tree.
Where is it?
Oh my god.
I just want the bare minimum.
Here, I'll show you guys the picture.
It was a giant-ass tree.
And I was like, I can't live up to that.
You're saying some unreal expectations for when he gets back
home.
And look at this.
Look at this big-ass tree.
What the fuck am I going to do?
he's got some fucking unreal expectations coming back i was
living in a prison whoa wait that is huge
uh gunball i think it was super chat thank you thank you
jacardo for chat thank you thank you and he gets to eat in
bed i what am i gonna do now he's still not home because i
have to travel again next week and i was like i'll extend
his vacation like you know i'm giving him the luxury of
having the vacation extended while i still have to fucking
work like so i have to yeah i have to i still have to travel
so i figured it'd easier um for him if i let him live a
couple of days more at the uh dog sitter and then i can and
then after i finish traveling next week then i'll pick him
up uh jacquarder think of a super chat thank you thank you
as a retro game fan hear about how good restory is sold i've
been meaning to check this game out to see doki oh sorry ep
doki playing this game is gonna be a fun time retro repair
doki thank you the super chat jacquarder thank you Thank
you.
Yeah, I've been looking forward to playing this for a while.
I remember seeing the trailers, and I've had it on my wish
list for a long time.
And I saw there was been a lot of really good reviews coming
out for the game.
So it seemed really fun, you know, like a chill repair shop
in Tokyo where you're repairing old appliances and retro
stuff.
It feels like something like a chill time.
So I've been wanting to check it out for a while.
Glad it's finally out.
It got it released when I was on vacation, so I'm glad I can
finally check it out.
But yeah, anyway, he's still, he's still there, which, by
the way, I need to order more food over there, like, we're
running out of food, can you order more?
But the thing is, I gave them one and a half boxes of food,
like, food, so I was like, oh, shit, we're already running,
I've been gone for a while now, I hope he remembers that
that is not the main house, I hope, I hope he remembers.
that that's the dog sitter and and home is back here let me
check out let me order this real quick to on amazon all
right let's see change to where where's their house i think
this is yeah this has to be their house uh or this address
Boom, boom, bip, bop, bam.
All right, cool business days.
All right, there we go.
No, it's worth food.
Ah, my dog sitter is coming over to take care of me.
I wonder how long this dog sitter is gonna take care before
I come back to my real home.
Anyway, so, uh i had to wake up early this morning that's
why i was taking a nap because i woke up really early at
like around nine ish a.m to clean up the apartment a little
bit before the plumber comes here uh because you know like
you know my life's a mess but i don't want him to know that
uh i even was like sorry it cleaned up a bit and then uh and
then i was like oh i'm so sorry um i just got back from a
work trip it's me i just i don't want him to judge like i
don't want this random stranger to judge me like i i already
let you guys judge me i don't want this random stranger that
knows where i live to judge me and i close my bedroom door i
close my bathroom door i close my turn off the lights in my
pc room close that though this clear door window thing and
then i was just like oh they're like oh yeah how long were
you gone for and i was like Um, like a month.
That's why it's so messy.
I just didn't have time to clean up right after.
Right after coming back.
Yeah.
That's gone for like a month.
That's why I'm so sorry.
It's like a bit of a mess.
The thing is I did clean up.
I did clean up before he arrived.
But then like obviously it's not as clean as I would have
liked it.
So I was like, oh, I'm sorry.
Sorry, it's a bit of a mess.
And then, Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Poor dad.
Five living in a castle.
I'm going to have to return to the evil stepmother, Toki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And then, you know, the, and then, um, who is it?
And then he was like, all right, so we're fixing the garbage
disposal.
I like how we were doing it together.
a group effort by the way.
I was part of the project too.
Hey it's my money so technically I paid my way into this.
Yeah we worked so hard to fix the garbage disposal which by
the way I realized like in Canada they call it the
garberator or some shit like why?
It's a Canadian thing um that in America we call it gar we
honorary American here as well we call it a garbage disposal
but again it's got garberator um these kept saying garberate
I'm like what the fuck is a garberator is a garbage disposal
disposes garbage um anyway so he looked inside I was I like
like right before my trip.
I like I was in a rush and I had just poured stuff into the
the garbage disposal but then the garbage disposal wasn't
working before I poured it but then I wasn't thinking about
it.
It was true.
That was true.
I pressed the garbage disposal button and I realized it
wasn't working and then I still poured it in because I was
like what if I pour stuff in and it'll work and I was by the
way I was in panic mode when I was doing that.
I was I was in panic mode because I was like five minutes
till till my till my Uber's here so I was just like oh fuck
okay I I wasn't I like like I will admit I was not thinking
so so I was just like so at that point I just left I
realized it's clogged and I left that I explained that like
by the way it was sort of not working before I poured it
because that was true um anyway so he attached the garbage
disposal and he looked into it and he's like oh yeah I see
the problem it's rusted the blades are rusted right now um
he was like you you don't use it often do you and I was like
no like that's true I don't I ordered out a lot I don't cook
a lot because I have no time so basically what I learned by
the way this is very important guys is very important for
all of you guys too I did not realize that was that like I
did not realize I was a thing but apparently if you don't
use your garbage disposal often like at least once a week it
will fucking rust and die I got what like what's the point
and it so so you actually have to use at least once a week
um so it won't fucking rust up because you need to like have
the water on it like once a week just so it won't like it
will keep moving yeah you have to use it or you lose it yeah
um and the thing is that's why that's why i didn't i didn't
know that because like this was the first time i've ever had
a garbage disposal uh in my apartment or like in in the
place i live i've never had a garbage disposal before um and
so uh so it's like it's like dishwashers too you have to use
it off you have to use it consistently or it will it will
actually like break down if you don't use it i know is that
so um so that he was like okay i can like uh he was like i
could clean it but like it's over for this guy like it's
it's over like there's no saving him because apparently the
motor also died my god like what how it's because the rust
the blades got rusted up and wasn't moving anymore so the
motor got burnt out because it can't move anymore um so
because of the rusted uh blades on the garbage disposal uh
the motor got burnt out so that's why so he was like i could
i don't have this specific because i was like fuck i'm not
telling my landlord about this that's gonna be future
dokey's problem whenever she moves out so so it is like i'll
He was like, I don't have a replacement for this.
I don't use like, I don't have a replacement for this
specific brand.
So he was like, but I can remove it and then install a
normal drain for you since you don't use a garbage disposal.
And then I was like, oh, it's like, I was just like humoring
him.
I was like, oh, how much would that?
Because I was like, I wasn't going to do that.
Like, I was going to like fucking remove that without my
landlord's permission.
by humor in him i was like oh how much would that cost he's
like seven hundred dollars and i was like yeah no like even
as a little he and see how much that gas i'm like no like so
i was just like oh can you we just clean it up and then i'll
just make sure to never drop anything into the sink again
like yeah so um yeah so i was just like oh let's just go
with the other option and just clean like just unclog as
much as you can and nothing will ever drop into that sink
again like so so that was the plan that i had um so by the
way um i oh my god that man must make so much money doing
doing it all he was very nice he's a very nice guy but holy
plumbing guys guys plumbing is a lucrative business you
gotta get in there quick before it's gone like but i got
charged less than an hour by it was like uh uh 40 i think
like 30 to 40 minute um appointment i'll tell him later i'll
tell him later not today
There's a 30 to 40 minute appointment.
And it cost me to unclog the garbage disposal and my train.
It cost me $500, like $565 for everything.
And I was just like, it could have been $700.
It could have been, it was $700 on top.
of it by the way they where he installed the drain it would
have been like a thousand something and i was like thank god
so it was like five hundred and sixty five dollars to to
unclog the drain and like unclog the garbage disposal and
everything he did give me a pro tip though he did tell me
how to like um like make sure to uh uh rinse the sink once a
week every sunday or something like uh to and so like with
hot water and it'll improve the sink health like it'll like
make sure it'll avoid like another clog in the future so i
was just like okay that's that's good advice for for me for
now yeah um so so uh i got a little some pro tips though i
got some everyday tip
Anyway, so It's no longer clogged anymore It's no longer
clogged It's just a garbage disposal is fucking dead Just
because I don't use it How is I supposed to This was my
first time owning a guy Having not even owning it I don't
even own that It was the first time I've ever had a garbage
disposal In a place I live And I didn't realize I had to use
it once a week Or a fucking start rusting and die like oh my
god like like i i just i didn't know uh maintenance it's a
landlord responsibility i just don't want to i like did a
lot like i okay i didn't do a lot i just i want a little
grace period between being like sos again like so i wanted
to give a little grace period before i'm like sos i have
another because he's a very nice landlord and I don't want
him to piss him off that's what that's why I'm like I'll
tell him later because at the at this moment there is like
nothing is wrong right now I sort of got it fixed so he's a
good landlord and I don't want to like be like I don't want
to be like what oh no my tent What did my tenant do this
time?
Yeah, I don't want to deal with that.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Time to play the game.
Let me boot it up.
It is a chill day.
Restory.
Yeah.
He doesn't know about the bathroom cabinet.
Because I felt like...
like okay oh my god i won't tell this never mind i'm not
gonna tell this story i baited you guys you're like oh no
don't you wanted to tell the story and she's not it's very
embarrassing i'm not gonna tell this story all right uh
maybe you could but you could buy the story off of me it's
like the paparazzi selling this story to the highest bidder
does it tmc want it uh affiliate thing ships they can think
who wants the exclusive story from donkey bird so
embarrassing that she's willing to sell the story sorry i
don't buy no it's not even a year old story it might the
later you tell the angry he'll be a bus especially he'll
that he won't know when it happened, guys.
Steve, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The cabinet's fixed now.
It's like nothing happened.
Cyber Dragon.
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
Cyber Dragon from TMC, the exclusive scoop.
Pay to win streamer to unlock the story.
You gotta, you gotta gotcha.
It was $10.
I am broken.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Mike, no, it's more embarrassing than the bathroom cabinet
door story.
Mr. Broken Pot.
Thank you.
Super chat.
The story she won't say it's because she broke her bathroom
cabinet door when leaning over to get more toilet paper.
Okay.
All right.
From Exclusive Scoop live right now.
So you know how it was at my friend's place?
during the couple of days that the sponsored tournament
tournament so it was very embarrassing so thank you for uh
unlocking the paywall because because i will need that for
later i might need to pay my i need might need to pay my
friend back later with a thank you from there captain door i
said it's more embarrassing and so so this will go towards
my friends funds my friends repair so so what happened was
that okay it's not even it's like partially not my fault so
i didn't realize this was possible because i've never had
this happen before just like the cabinet door so what
happened was okay okay think about physics real quick just
think about how physics can play a part to this so i was in
their bathroom they didn't have toilet paper in that
bathroom um Steve, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But they had wet wipes instead.
the thing is, the wet wipes, I knew I should have picked it
up and placed it in the closer spot.
So, the wet wipes was like, sort of like, okay, I'll give
you a visual.
I'll give you a visual.
So, yeah.
This is like my friends, my friends, please.
So I was...
So, okay, okay, give me a second.
I should put this a little closer, okay?
So, all right.
So, all right, so this is a little visual.
on what was going on was in the bathroom.
Okay.
And you're like, why are you laughing so hard?
I think I'm a talented artist.
that's where the wet wipes are.
And so instead of like next to me, you're close to me.
The wet wipes was there.
I don't know why it was there.
It was just my friend just had it placed there and so so i i
didn't want to get up i so i at the edge of the toilet seat
i lean down at the edge of the toilet seat i remember
physics play a huge part physics is a huge part Trying to
lead it down to grab it.
And then the toilet snapped.
And the toilet seat broke because you're not supposed to put
all the weight at the edge of the toilet seat.
So, one of the things, it didn't snap in half, by the way.
It didn't snap in half.
It was just like, it was like, okay, so I'll try.
It was like, it was like here, this is where it snapped
right here.
Because, because you're, because you're putting all the way
of water.
one side and that's a big I've never had that app I was so
embarrassed I was just like I I was like oh fuck and I went
and then I went over like I'm so sorry I had so it's that
part
yeah so so it was that part that snapped and I was like it
was like and I was like oh I hope that's a sound.
I hope that's, yeah, only the C is the C.
And I was just like, I don't hear the BAP.
And I was like, man, I hope that's not a bad sound.
And I turned around.
And I was like, oh, oh, it was not, in fact, not a good
sound.
down all right the clipper's gonna go crazy this one dr
funder thank you thank you thank you um elka saying you was
super chat thank you thank you on one hand at least you
didn't hurry yourself on the other hand uh god damn it don't
keep forward thank you with yaka super thank you thank you
for your friend no i didn't break the tire toilet i would
never i that story would have died with me I would fucking
die with that story I would never fucking fucking it was the
The seat It was like the seat thing at the end that cracked
I would never Never leave Leave my mouth That story will
stay Dead with me
Yeah and yeah I would not told you that happened so uh
basically yeah so i cracked the seat over here it was just
that one area because i like i said i put all my weight at
the edge and be like to pick up the wet wipes because i
didn't want to get up i didn't want to get up so um so and
then yeah it's easily replaceable at least you know you just
need to get the right toilet seat to replace it.
I was like, I was like, it was reachable.
It was reachable, you know?
Chicago, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We've been seeing Doki's Life is Secretless sitcom as a joke
for a while, but now this story right here basically
confirms our theory.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
with a super chat thank you thank you tokey their puppies
are less destructive than you they give a super chat thank
you thank you and so so anyway i had to break the news to my
friend and i went over went over to them was like hey i have
some bad news but please don't be too angry i will pay for
it i was just like please don't be mad i will pay for it.
And don't tell your dad.
Don't tell your dad.
It's just like, don't tell your dad.
I'll pay for it.
That's a bad starting.
I just don't want to piss off.
They're dead.
I don't want them to know.
need to be spread out to like other people i thank you um uh
simple thank you most super chat thank you thank you because
technically the toilet and like the place i was at it was
like owned by their dad so so i was just like don't tell
your dad about what i will just get a repairman get a
handyman and then get it fixed and i will pay you for it
that's simple-minded thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you turkey quick no no no no it's not that type of
situation uh solid thank you a super chat thank thank you
friend fun and since it was just a seat it was probably a
goner anyway to be honest so not that bad because it did not
break the entire toilet it was just the seat guys it was
just this the fucking seat because of the because of physics
if you guys didn't know you're never supposed to put all the
weight at the edge because then physics wise it does not do
so well as As you can see with the cracked toilet seat.
With the...
And it's easy to replace.
Thank God.
It's very easy to replace.
Terminated.
I think the worst part is just me doing that at my friend's
place.
I think that's the worst part.
Terminated.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's like a little science lesson.
you know little physics lesson for all of you guys um on one
hand joki how dumb are you enough are you how are you dumb
enough to not figure out you can use your feet on the hand
other hand though how is your butt that powerful have you
ever okay have you ever done like get like a fucking stick
or like anything breakable like even a ruler and you put it
um you put all your weight like all your weight at the edge
it's it's like if you push it and then like like a little
bit of the ruler is just on like the table and then you you
push everything else down it will snap very easily that is
that it's literally it's physics guys it's the force and
stuff whatever
physics um yavi thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you toilet puns thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you um chicago thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you i just realized the irony that doki is about to play a
repair game right after the garbage disposal repair and
toilet that needs repair story it's like doki now has to be
the repair person today thank you
It's physics!
For F equals MA.
I don't know what M or A stands for.
But I assume F stands for force.
You can't fight gravity.
I'm exactly, I'm proving, okay, I'm proving the Vulcan point
right now.
Simple-minded, thank you, Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
The real question is how much are you willing to pay for us?
Not to tell me.
Thank you with a super chat.
Thank you.
I gave you the exclusive TMZ scoop.
Are you not happy now?
I let you buy the story.
Yeah, I used the force to break my friend's toilet seat.
The toilet seat.
Griffin, thank you with a super chat.
Thank you.
All right, let's look at this real quick.
Uh, 120, fuck it, 120 is fine.
Alright, let's go fix some shit.
With great power comes great responsibility.
I've learned my lesson, guys.
I should have just got up.
Clean up the work area and sort out the inventory and throw
away boxes.
Alright, where the fuck...
Okay.
Oh, I have Zen.
I might need it.
I definitely need that.
I need the scent.
Where would I put my clock?
I have a clock.
Where would I put it?
Sorry, I'm going to throw away boxes.
All right.
Hello.
How are you getting on?
Clean up.
I'm here about the rent.
That's what we read.
2,000 yen per week.
That's not too bad.
That's pretty cheap.
The yen is really bad right now.
too i heard like i heard it's actually really really bad
right now in japan the economy and the the value of the yen
is actually not ideal and a lot of people in japan are very
frustrated about it right now oh i see something are they is
is nepris talking about kjo i don't even have to read i saw
there was a silly anime series where women i saw that and i
was like they're talking about finish what you're talking
about.
Context wise, I know instantly you're talking about K-Jew.
I know, I don't worry.
I finished that anime when it came out.
Nephirs, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The butts of Babylon.
Let's go.
I love that anime.
It's my favorite.
It's honestly one of my favorites.
on the way here i found a phone i didn't know whose but it's
mine now everything here is mine although it doesn't turn on
how much would it cost to repair uh well he's my landlord i
shouldn't piss him off the first customer gets it for free
uh you'll end up like the last mile i was just trying to be
what happened to hospitality what's the point of being a
landlord if you can't take advantage of it.
When you're done, put the phone on the counter.
I'll be around here somewhere.
Kejo is exactly is best.
Like, move aside Blue Lock.
You will never be like Kejo.
I was like, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Service is clean.
Okay, 4,000.
Oh, hey, there's a number.
We got, ooh, hey, a girl new phone who's this okay and then
oh i'm not i'm not remembering any of these
oh no there'll definitely be a problem reassembling this all
right see you thank you with the super chat thank you thank
you i should actually remember where i put where i'm putting
it all of these kit bam all right i got all the parts okay
that's dirty how do i clean
all right here we go oh it's just that easy
nice all right what else is dirty the function buttons all
right that's nice Time to dust for fingerprints and find out
who owns this phone.
Not creepy at all, ma'am.
Just want to know who the owner is.
Oh, it's a Pokia phone!
Oh my god, it's a Nokia!
My mom had that phone before.
Alright.
Oh, this is dirty.
The battery.
It's gonna explode one day.
I think that's the scary part about old...
phones battery packs that one day it's gonna explode you
don't know when it's gonna be Steve thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you uh I think I can okay I got pieced
everything back together now I can remember this all right
uh okay
where was this okay it was right here oh my god it's like a
little puzzle see
you guys i can remember oh i didn't tune that too what else
am i missing
Oh my god, did I screw it or did I unscrew it?
I can't.
Oh shit, wait.
All right.
I unscrewed it back.
What am I supposed to do?
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, am I supposed to re-screw?
Oh my god, I was supposed to fully unscrew this.
Aren't I?
All right.
Lefty Lucy.
Screw it, well.
Now it should be fine.
Alright, nice.
I did it.
Got the Pokey phone.
Whoa, oh, yeah!
It's fixed.
Perfect.
Alright.
Nice.
I even packed it up.
Oh, so I have in the box.
I can't stand Akiba.
noise, the crowds, but it's more peaceful here with you.
What are you doing?
Is the phone ready?
I don't have much time.
Oh, yeah.
I'll mention the paper.
I know that number.
In short, you may be contacted.
It'll be better for you if you don't answer and in general.
It really should close before midnight.
There was an incident last night.
Somebody broke into a store.
It ransacked everything and stole some expensive equipment.
My son was on the scene.
He came home angry and wet.
rates too but we'll oh it's all connected it's all it's a
family business that's for sure the best part about this job
i can come in with my pajamas oh hey 4 000 yen excuse the
extrusion i hope i didn't scare you the last master always
gets scared i live directly above you i'm taking part in an
online pac-man championship on my old atari two thousand two
thousand six hundred but my joystick broke and i'm so close
to the record time this month.
So now I got two broken joysticks.
Oh, that's so convenient.
He's Yakuza.
Yeah, he seems to be a Kuzza.
Can you fix one of them at least?
Just tug the rope if you agree.
I mean, business is business.
I'll fucking fix this.
How bad can it be?
Alright.
Uh, okay, most likely I'll need parts.
Okay, how do I?
How do I?
Alright, it's right here in the holes all right screwy
screwy lefty loosey righty tidy oh no no no uh it's
unscrewed now oh there we go okay unknown part dirty uh no
point in keeping broken parts all right what's the other the
Oh my god, what the fuck did you do to the accord?
Alright, time to dust it for prints.
In case there was a murder!
You won't know.
It's like any item can be a murder object.
Okay, I need...
Well, I threw it away.
I don't have any parts.
Uh...
Well, then...
How do I get new parts?
Okay, I should put this in first.
I mean, maybe this is salvageable.
Maybe.
Maybe I can, like, Frankenstein this.
Maybe he has parts in here that can be used to...
We can do a surgery, you know?
Oh my god, is that mold?
Is that fucking black mold in your circuit board?
What the fuck happened?
Okay, that's bro.
Oh, yeah!
We didn't do a surgery!
Okay, we can use this part and this part, and then we'll,
there, that is no saving you.
There's no saving you.
I'll dust it, though.
I'll clean it, though, just for fun.
He just needs one joystick, guys.
That's all he needs.
All right, and then this, goodbye.
All right.
Let's see.
Before you stand, Inspector...
Oh, that's the sun.
Sakamoto.
Oh, yeah, sound guy.
Let me know the sounds, alright.
There's barely any sound, but, you know, just for fun.
Oh, yeah.
Also, I forgot.
Chilling time.
I'm going to extend the birthday merch another week just
because I keep forgetting to...
Forgetting to tweet about it.
So, one more week!
Free or Oh, is he mail?
No, he's inspected.
Pre-order your birthday merch before it's gone.
I'm not correcting that.
It's fine.
Gone.
I'm going to get the birthday merch, guys.
Where he's sent.
There's a little case I'm investigating.
See, I told you.
It could be a murder.
Somebody broke into a store, smashed the windows, and made
out of expensive equipment.
I chased him all the way to the Canada River.
In the struggle, I fell straight into the water.
I'm fine.
Oh, yeah, see, it is the sun.
It sounds good, Doki.
All right.
Now that you said it sounds good, I don't need to finish the
other sentence you wrote.
He must have been complimenting how much of a great stream
he's watching.
It won't turn on.
Can you please take a look?
The flashlight is my faithful partner.
When I turned it on, smoke came out of it.
Oh, my.
Just buy a new flash, bro.
Just buy.
At that point, just get a new flashlight.
back to the basement you go it's a popular model but you
can't get parts for it here anymore still if it's so popular
wouldn't it be easily replaceable
just be sure to check the seller's ratings people lie people
lie on the internet tell them i still don't look they can't
lie to me i don't have the internet i know an internet guy
he's a little odd but he knows what he's doing i'll send him
to you By the way, this is a retro store, guys.
We're being immersed here.
Nothing past 2000.
By the way, I'm surprised that somebody opened up again here
so quickly after the business or the last master.
But you seem to know what you're doing, so good luck.
All right.
Well, I'm going to fix this first.
Hey, if he wins, maybe he'll...
look if he wins maybe he'll give me some of the prize
winnings um right here here there you go bam and it's fixed
even more dokey merch i spent almost 200 only in dokey merch
during last week it's convention my wallet's gonna hang me
don't worry you have one more week you have one week to
decide do not worry see but you would get like slippers a
blank blanket and um and a little acrylic panel all right
let's see all right i'm done oh all right you just gotta
come in wait how do i have a pc but no internet i'm sorry
i'm sorry you fixed already right here's the payment for
your work it should be enough and you can keep the second
joystick i already did you still don't have internet can i
help it's so nice be able to do something useful.
See, guys, look at that.
Got internet.
He's an advert from our provider.
They have the best rate.
Write in your answer what speed you want.
Oh, 50.
Let's go.
High speed?
Good.
Okay, maybe not.
Maybe just the smart plan.
Look at the smart plan.
I don't think I need a good for professional.
I don't think I'd be gaming anytime here when I'm stuck in
this little hidey hole.
Look at the smart plan.
Sorry, I have one more favorite to ask.
I bought a portable Nomi PMP.
Oh, it's a PSP on the marketplace.
It was hard to get, as it's only just come up, but it
doesn't.
Don't worry.
There's gonna be plenty more PMPs out there.
I don't think I think PSPs were really popular in Asia, but
they were definitely not popular in NA.
I felt.
They died.
They died real.
It was just too ahead of its time, you know?
I think the PSP was too ahead of its time.
and it was not as popular in any but it was so popular in
asia do not worry you'll find so much more psps yeah
it was solid it was just i think it was just was it too i
don't remember it because like i never got psp my dad got it
for his birthday so i just mooched off my dad's psp um but i
just knew that i just remember it was just it didn't sell as
much as they wanted to
Let's see But it doesn't turn on The box was all crumpled So
the quarry of Mia dropped in hurry On forms error writes
that only official surfaces Can perform repairs I don't get
out much So you're my only hope You do have a license to...
Yeah, nope Well, where's the no button?
Where can I lie?
Man Why give me a choice If it's one choice This might as
well just Auto dialogue it What a pity.
Never mind.
I'll wait.
As soon as you have a PMP license, I'll be in touch.
Oh, hey, I have the internet now.
I have Gozilla Fair.
Poke.
Oh, my God.
Igo, Daichi, Atari.
How do I get a license?
Oh, wait.
I'll accept it.
Oh, yeah.
I'll do that.
It doesn't work properly.
I need to take all of it.
I don't know why I wasn't used for a week.
All right, let's see.
Oh my god, I can make more money at Home Depot.
Oh, there's the parts.
The air duster.
How do I...
Can I take online test?
Oh, there you go.
40,000 yen?
There's not enough PMPs to make up for this.
The yen is very weak right now.
There's not enough funds.
Oh, yeah, and tomato boxes.
I forgot the Pista resistance.
The tomato boxes.
The star of the merch.
Thank you, Super Chat Steve.
Thank you, thank you.
Would have been nice for the option.
Oh, yo, you do.
You get one of each.
Don't worry.
You actually do get one of...
Oh, wait.
I fucking screwed it back on.
The pack comes with both boxers.
So don't worry.
So, if you're, you know, if you want the face to be on the
ass or on your crouch, we have, you have so many choices to
choose from.
Is that all?
Okay, there's the battery.
I think that's everything.
Okay, circuit board is fucked.
Side panels.
All right, I need a new bulb.
New that.
New circuit board.
Then clean this.
All right.
And then clean that.
Alright, and then I got order.
Oh my god, where is it?
Where are the parts for the shit parts?
Where's flashlight?
Out of stock.
It's out of stock.
Oh wait, no, I don't need it.
I need, oh my.
Okay, circuit board.
Light.
Okay, out.
It's a light bulb.
How can you be out?
I might as well just, I'm just gonna, it doesn't turn off.
All right, maybe he has the circuit board.
I'll buy this.
And then Pope to God.
That works.
Oh, my God.
I can have stickers, though.
Should I buy parts?
Or do I just buy some stickers?
All right, well, I don't know what to do.
Hey there, are you the new master?
Oh, I'm so glad you've opened up.
Now I have something to do.
The last master.
missing but suddenly and it's been see if they give us super
chat they get that yeah it comes that's why I was like I
couldn't choose I like both options so I was like why not
just give you guys both options like it's like these like
you know do I feel like today today is it like a butt face
day or a crotch face day you know like if I'm on a date
right now do I want her to see my crunch yeah i'm so glad
you've opened up okay i feel like i should have less maybe
that's why rent is so fucking cheap the fucking last master
disappeared yeah mr hashimoto said that you need help
delivering bills and orders and picking up goods for sale
just put everything on the counter so what have you got here
aha here are the bills rent it in here i'll bring them in
every week okay i'll go now in my work speed is of the
essence whoosh all right what do i have here all right rent
oh my god did he just give me more stuff to pay oh wait i
got money here okay internet nice paid my bills what what's
in here okay might as well just put these parts in here oh
wait i could sell it no i'll hoard these parts i don't think
i need to sell it yet um oh i have lights oh that's nice um
and i have a radio
alright find a donor on the marketplace and fix the
flashlight and not oh it's oh rackerton buy a license
service license buy sell and order Oh, do I not have it?
Oh, I do.
Okay, now I have music.
I do need... Okay, wait.
What parts do I need again?
I need bulb, cup, and circuit board.
Bulb, cup, and circuit board.
There is a bulb.
Where's the circuit board?
A thousand?
Is that the right circuit board I need?
Thousand You know, I'll buy this for now.
And then...
Just because I don't...
I'll just grab the circuit board just in case.
Alright.
Now it's just a waiting game.
I have nothing to do.
Oh, wait.
Is this junk?
Bucket.
Buy a Nomi PMP license.
Oh my god.
Was that board for the entire...
Well...
It's alright.
It's okay.
It's fine.
It's for my job for later Whoops Okay, it's sold out anyway
It's sold out, I just have to wait I have nothing to do I
already bought the fucking thing I have to wait two to three
business days Where the fuck is like my order
Where I check the click the green box Oh wait, what the fuck
Where did this come from?
Where did...
All right.
I didn't even see that.
I was like, where did this come from?
I forgot there's this giant green box.
Like, all right, just time to wait it out.
I was willing to like wait it out until the next day.
Business hours are closed.
My hours are like 3 to 5 p.m.
And on Sunday, it's...
3.30 to 4 p.m.
That's when you know business is booming.
I can justify these hours because of how much business I
have.
What else needs cleaning?
Option button.
Alright.
Clean.
What else?
Keyboard option button.
Okay, still the option button apparently.
hey i'm the manager of this i make my own hours guys as the
manager to my own store where the fuck is the where did that
oh it's right here
okay that here
all right screw some stuff in
give me a sec i'm working right now y'all wait like
everybody yeah i'm my own boss i make my hours i'm an
independent businesswoman all right nice clean perfect
little girl sensei sensei help my igodachi doesn't respond
anymore he wants to give her my mom oh she's your igodachi's
dead little girl my class went on excursion she he's poop
right now i'm sorry to tell you you didn't feed your
igodachi within 30 minutes he's poop right now.
It was so high up there and so beautiful.
But I got to distract and drop my Igodachi straight into a
puddle.
I've done everything I could.
I fed him rice balls and wrapped him in a towel.
But the screen still won't light up.
I shook him, blew on him, and he even said sorry, but he
still... Oh, he's about to learn what death is.
Fix him, please.
He promised he'd grow up to be a huge dragon.
Alright.
Wait, device... Wait, where's the other device that happened
to the... Wait, minute.
Put the Igodachi here.
Where's the other device?
Why is it all?
What the fuck away is here?
Is this the which one's the finished one?
Alright, there it is.
Alright, let's grab this out.
Okay, is this bulb fine?
This bulb is fine.
We'll put that bulb here.
And then we need that cover anyway.
Well, she's gonna learn what death is.
It's a time to grow up, little girl.
Alright, I'm screwed this.
Is this fine?
Yeah, this is fine.
Side panel's broken.
That's not good.
The side panel was the one thing I need.
Okay, how about this?
The battery's broken.
Um, alright.
There we go.
that I can fix this oh oh shit this was somebody else's
order wait no this is up this is his order all right I was
gonna say oh shit battery I need all of this okay uh side
panel circuit board side panel light bam now I have extra
side panel all right fixed it yeah yakuza won't have to come
over now did you guys hear about the new um someone made a i
don't know we just have so much free time now i vibe coding
has taken us so far now but someone made a new phone app
where it's like you send a virtual carrier pigeon and your
virtual where it'll take like like two to three business
days for you to receive a message from your friends and then
your pit your virtual ping uh sorry peg your virtual pigeon
has a chance to fucking die like what your virtual pigeon
can fucking die which is crazy let me show you guys the
tweet i saw it i was like what the fuck you could just send
a letter The message can't be lost because it dies or
something.
It just never makes it.
They caught my pigeon, bro.
Alright, I don't know what.
What's wrong with your Igodachi?
I mean, there's water on it.
It's like a fucking 2...
I am the future.
It's like from the 2000s.
So I don't know if we can...
I don't know if we have enough rice to fix this little.
girl yeah the pigeon got killed by a virtual ego
sorry i couldn't give you the message
okay are any parts broken oh it's just all dirty all right
that's fine
the digi the digi hawk ate the pigeon we're sorry you should
get like a fucking uh message about that like sorry dad
kissed the hawk virtual hawk ate it it's like rng your
fucking message we gamble it I need everything now even text
message the thrill of whether or not your pigeon dies isn't
that exciting
uh everything everything Where the fuck is the backplate of
this?
Oh, there we go.
I was like, how am I supposed to put this together?
Alright.
Screwy, screwy.
And then put these back on.
Oh, there's so many screws.
Oh.
Alright, last screw.
Alright, little girl, it's fixed.
Oh my god, I'm fucking 4,000 yen?
Yeah, I'm fucking fleecing this kid.
She's going to learn a lot today.
That's right.
I'm teaching her about the real world.
4,000 yen.
For me to fucking dust a couple of...
Just dust a fucking...
Tomagachi.
Did it in like five...
Like in five minutes, too.
Teaching...
Yeah, I'm extorting her lunch money.
didn't want to piss off her mom that'll be 4 000 yen
polymark can predict five dollars if my pigeon will make it
to its destination
all right what is broken control panel screen lens button
call all right control i'll take that accept order accept
order uh i'm gonna have to order a new Igodachi, a thousand.
It was my son.
I don't understand these things.
Doesn't turn on.
It beeps all the time.
I hit it, but it was a point on these toys anyway.
Is it worth it?
Any screen lens fun?
Okay.
I ordered this.
Oh, nope.
Ordered a thousand one.
Should be fine.
And I'll just clean this for now.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, it's 5 in the morning.
I've been working all night.
Okay, what's wrong with this, Nokia?
Alright, it's just very dirty.
I don't see anything else actually wrong with it.
I need to get an electric screwdriver.
I'm fucking doing this like a peasant!
Maybe that's why the old master died.
He couldn't move on with the times.
The future is now old, man.
but everything is just dirty something wrong with it you
know what i'm gonna make an investment right now this is why
his store failed where is it where's the duster home depot
there let's go efficiency yeah oh my god and there's a
ratchet screwdriver oh my god the electric screwdriver This
is why he was never able to improve his store.
All right, let's see.
This doesn't...
Where was it?
Oh, there is the battery.
Oh my god, that one was so dusty.
Bro, this Nokia phone was cheaper.
The repair for this was cheaper than the Iguodachi.
Every screw.
Every screw I unscrew costs like a thousand.
That kid's gonna learn.
That kid's gonna learn for wasting my fucking time.
Good.
Let's see.
Alright.
Yeah, it's time to modernize.
I mean, you didn't even have internet here.
Nice.
Alright, done.
Perfect.
Okay, and then...
Oop.
That should be everything.
Uh...
Well, what am I gonna do to pass the time now?
So I should throw these away.
I'll clean up.
It's like that lady.
What's that lady called where she was like, does this make
me happy?
Or shit?
What the fuck do I do?
I finished it.
Okay.
What's this?
Oh, yeah, that's the parts I still need to get the parts
Ring ring Is there like, I don't know Okay, I'll have two
apps on here Email or Firefox Yeah, does it bring me joy?
I see you brought my old friend back to life Here's your
reward, yay You don't mind if I ask a few questions do you
What, if I committed that murder last Tuesday?
Of course not Say that you'd be happy to answer And don't
want any trouble I'll be happy to answer Excellent.
I don't want to piss him off.
He seems like Trump.
He seems like a bad cop.
With regard to the incident last night, I'm convinced that
Hashimoto...
Oh, oh, the incident last night.
Not about the murder.
That's not yet been discovered.
Oh, of course.
Of course, of course.
I'm convinced that Hashimoto is involved somehow, but we
don't have much information.
Do you know anything?
Oh, yeah.
What about the number I have?
Do I have a phone here?
Um...
Repeat Hashimoto.
How his son came home?
and angry see you thought he was i i did thought he was
sashimoto's son sorry i don't really get the joke why on
earth made you think that uh but how his son came on wet and
angry that night so it was his boy we've been getting
complaints about him for a while that really helps
investigation i'm so glad you saved my flashlight i didn't
want to lose it right i'll be off i stand out here like a
cat in the kimono all right nice job well done i wasn't
snitching on anybody guys oh what happened oh day two
oh it's eight oh did i end at the day accident is that how
you end it oh yay now it's day three
I lost the entire day of business.
Yay!
I heard you were looking for me.
How can I be?
Tell them about the girl in Iggo, Dadgy.
Oh, class will see you're on an excursion.
Look, I told you guys, my business hours on Sunday is 3.30
to 4.
all right i took the day off you ask grandma found out where
they're from you should at least have asked her a name i bet
you didn't pay this shit i'll take the igla dot you and pay
for my own money i earned a little extra today already uh
take the money kids get free service take the money and take
the girl take the money
damn right you take that money all right what's this order
oh shit all that money wait what i didn't even finish
repairing the egodachi did i just i didn't i didn't finish i
didn't finish fucking okay i didn't finish repairing I'm
here on personal business.
I brought the phone on the marketplace, but I need to get it
working.
Do you think you could do that?
It's for my scam, the child.
I have 4,000 yen richer, guys.
I was going to say it.
It's because I accidentally skipped a day.
I think it's because I accidentally skipped a day.
It's a rare auto roll Limited edition I really hope she'll
like it Alright Oh Hello Moto Is it Hello Moto Okay Um I
think it's because I skipped a day And then Yeah it was so
broken I never finished I never finished repairing it Okay
Okay Nice.
And she learned something new today, guys.
What did I need?
She learned a life lesson.
Which is because I hope they too wasn't important, guys.
I hope they too wasn't that important.
And they fixed themselves.
Whoops.
Hey, it fixed itself.
Oh, God.
That's definitely going to trash.
Back panel is broken.
Yeah, I gotta keep this, though.
Okay, and then we gotta grab the other one.
Okay, I need...
Oh, I still need a front panel, a screen lens, and a button.
Okay, wait, I do have front panel.
Front panel, screen lens.
button.
All right, here we go.
It should be everything I need.
We have two front panel.
Okay, now I have one front panel.
Which one?
This is the broken one.
Okay, and then this is the broken screen lens.
All right, now I can piece everything together.
Okay, and then I'll put this.
Oh, I have it here.
All right.
I always screw these in.
Where the fuck do I get my duster, though?
Screw these in.
Oh, my God, I'm making so much money.
I'm so efficient right now.
I say as I clocked out after one or eight last night, I'm so
efficient, guys.
All right, nice.
Job done.
All right, what's wrong with this?
Oh, it looks so new.
What is wrong with it?
Oh, he just wants me to clean it.
How much am I getting paid?
$2,000 to clean it?
Oh, I'm practically scamming people.
Should have been a repairman.
This is tired.
Guys, see, guys?
Don't go to college.
Don't listen to me.
Don't you said don't go to college.
I'm going to drop out right now.
what's the what's that college for repairing everything i
mean i can screw more that door two layer already dropped
out jesus this is complicated
what else am i unscrewing it or am i screwing i can't tell
Okay.
There is a you make sure Doki fit.
That's how Magachi do you remember a track record, right?
Is that everything?
There's still unknown parts?
Oh, here we go.
Alright, what needs cleaning?
Switches.
This switch.
There's still more dirt on it.
Trade school.
Yeah, I think trade school is...
It's a more, I mean, that plumber's got so much, got $500
from me in a 40-minute job.
I think trade school is definitely more worth, more worth
than that, because people don't really know how to do shit
anymore, including I'm people.
That's me, by the way, I'm people.
I'm talking about me.
Let's see.
I don't think this would this job would work in NA though
not gonna lie me I mean it'd be very specialized but also I
feel like there's not enough I can I guess like if you're
like the one of the best repair people because a lot of
people do collect retro shit too um retro stuff but I'm
losing track on which way is the right side but I don't know
if it's as lucrative as as working Japan.
Yeah, but people mostly it's just like, no, but I meant like
usually people would like repair phones and stuff, but not
like retro, you know, retro consoles.
That's what I'm thinking of.
I'm thinking about like the niche market, about the
repairing retro consoles.
I see, I know there's like on you, you can make a lot of
making content out of it on YouTube and stuff, because I
know it's like really popular on YouTube.
I don't know where I put this here.
Oh.
all right nice all right i'm moving up in the world oh i got
sick oh they heard they heard about my my retro repair shop
i knew making a website would would be good i'm on home
depot guys check me out it's at home depot all right
i registered my handyman there it's not a lot of retro
repair people We're Home Depot, guys.
All of it.
How many are parts?
Yeah, replacement parts must be really hard.
That's why you just buy, like, um...
I don't know.
Did I unscrew everything?
I can't tell.
I had to buy, like, other people's, um, like, broken phones
or gadgets and knickknacks.
All of it.
I still have, like, four more unknown parts.
what more can i what more can i do oh here it's so tiny i
can't tell sometimes all right what needs cleaning display
sorry time to spray oh my god this is i'm fucking pure
efficiency right now optimization i'm optimizing okay we
need to buy a new phone i'll take that one too um does
anyone else have one doesn't turn on I'm gonna risk it um do
I have a license yet 40,000 okay split oh my god why would I
ever use a brush again antenna guys I'm optimizing um
antenna No, don't risk it.
It'll be fine.
It'll be fine I'll just I got some rice
Oh wait it runs out.
Oh my god.
I didn't realize that's what the main eater meant.
What do you mean?
Oh, I have to dust it out You don't drug it.
It's worth it.
I don't care I'll just buy another one Yeah, I'll use it
What do you mean?
I'll just pump more air back into it.
I need a circuit board.
Okay, I hope the water damage didn't damage the circuit
board.
Guys, maybe it didn't damage the circuit board, guys.
Okay.
Oh, that's a lot of orders.
Oh, wait.
Is this the...
Oh, this person needs...
Just to clean it?
Alright, that's fine.
I know how to do this one
And then this one here Yeah, as we all know Circuit boards
are waterproof It's a very good We all know that guys One of
the most common things about circuit boards Is that they're
very waterproof
Alright Got this out everything
okay there you go all right one needs cleaning front panel
nice that's done this is very relaxing though I can see why
this game does really well people just want to you know
there's a website in Korea I think it's in Korea right where
you can pretend to do where you can pretend to buy stuff and
uh do your dailies or whatever right what is that what it is
just to like relax from the heart from basically life you
guys heard about that it was a while ago yeah it's like fake
shopping website for like retail fake retail therapy
it's like simulate shopping let me see it let me look it up
i thought it was super interesting uh what was it called
yeah sub korea events fake shopping sites where you can
browse fill a cart and track a delivery but nothing ever
ships i was just like it's so you can get like the small hit
of control and dopamine you feel when you click add to cart
your dopamine actually spikes in anticipation not the
delivery of the thing so you don't spend why not go to real
money.
That's the whole point.
So you don't spend actual real money.
That's like therapeutic in a way.
Where is this supposed to go?
I've already lost track where things are supposed to go.
You know, instead of learning to actually how to repair
stuff, I can pretend.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so good at pretending.
I could actually do this, guys.
Guys, I think I can actually become a repairman.
Because I'm so good at this.
Maybe I should open up my own shop, guys.
Alright.
Oh, I got that.
Nice.
Oh my god, I have so many.
Maybe I...
Guys, I might have taken too many orders.
I might have taken too many orders.
There is a possibility.
Okay, oh, this is the one I've been looking for.
What do I need?
Okay, not that.
Not in a way.
That looks fine.
That circuit board looks so healthy right now.
It's just a little dirty, guys.
Okay.
No, please.
Yeah!
I knew it.
All in.
Yeah, we're going to put that in here.
It's a little dirt.
See, I told you.
All right, what's broken?
Everything's just a little dirty.
Just put everything in here.
I'll need to clean everything up.
All right, and then grab the other guy's phone.
Where's his phone?
Is it Yamato?
Yeah, there it is.
it is.
All right.
I need a circuit board.
I just and back panel.
Uh, back panel circuit board.
Thank God.
See you guys, I told you.
No need to worry.
It's just a little water.
I told you guys.
I knew it.
I knew circuit boards are waterproof.
See, I'm a professional.
You didn't believe, you laughed.
You laughed at me, but look who's laughing now.
They are waterproof.
I know a Miami guy that runs a retro shop that used to be a
Nintendo repair center so yeah it's repaired to us that
other places won't normally have oh thank you for the super
chat they could think I think it's very I used to watch like
retro repair videos because I think it's it's very
interesting um like the process that goes behind it you know
Um...
Here.
I'm a professional.
That's what you would like to hear from your repairman.
Uh...
Just a little bit of trial and error real quick.
There you go.
Alright.
See, I know what I'm doing.
BAM!
There you go.
Now give it to your wife.
He's gonna get some tonight.
Okay, throw that away.
What a beauty.
She's gonna love it.
Her ship ensued.
Thank you so much.
I'm off.
Alright, let's see.
Wish him luck.
Yay, money!
I'm almost close to PSP license.
Alright, what's this job?
Prepare and clean.
Yeah, I know.
Alright, let's get the...
cleaning out of the way.
What about this?
Clean.
Alright, cleaning is easy.
Alright, I'll wrap that out.
So there's no dead bugs living under there.
Did you hear about that?
You saw the Twitter post?
That Twitter post where
this lady was wondering why, like, oh, whenever she fried
rice, there was, like, a...
Whenever she makes rice, there was a smoky fried feeling to
her, taste to her rice and then she looked under her...
Was it her rice cooker?
She... Not rice cooker.
What was it?
She looked under, like, her appliance and in it...
She, like, uncapped it and it was just a bunch of dead
lizards.
Dead fried lizards.
Just... Just dead fried lizards underneath the cover of her
appliance.
I don't even remember what appliance she had.
Air cooker.
Oh, it was an air fryer.
Yeah.
Yeah, and that was what was giving the smoky fried feeling.
She didn't clean her.
She didn't clean the bottom of her air fryer.
Yeah, free seasoning.
Exactly.
Anyway, remember to look at the bottom of your air fryer,
guys.
I don't know which one is screwed and which one isn't.
Okay, is that...
Did I screw it in?
Okay.
two switches there it is it's fine and then this one too you
know oh my god i should just have done that oh all right now
piece it all back together
now tiny ass screw
hello hello what am i missing on that screw I forgot
something else in there.
Oh, this.
Oh, a dirty part has been installed.
Oh, did I forget?
Oh, no wonder it was white.
Whoops.
That makes sense.
Yeah, preseason rice cooker.
Yeah, someone was like, hey, you like the taste.
Why?
What's so wrong with it?
I mean, it's true.
I mean, unfortunate that it was just dead fried lizards it's
just a little bit unfortunate all right nice okay the gross
one was the video of like some girl that was apparently
eating like uh diced up maggots um from her blender because
she didn't clean the bottom of her blender or some shit that
one is maybe you got that one It is a problem.
Yeah.
All right, clean.
I did that.
Oh, my God.
Where the fuck did you do with your phone?
Like, oh, my God.
Did you lose it in, like, a drain or some shit?
Yeah, that's horrible.
Let's go on with me.
It came from the...
It was the same algorithm.
It was the same post.
It was, like, quote retweet.
Okay.
I'm trying to remember which one I need to unscrew.
Oh my god, I need to buy an electric screwdriver.
Fuck this.
All right, electric.
God damn it, so I'm buying this.
I'm investing.
I can't be bothered to do these screwing stuff.
Wait, can I get my PSP license?
I'm so tired.
What?
What am I missing?
Unscrewed everything.
Except for that.
But I swear to God I unscrewed everything.
Okay, where am I?
Keyboard.
Alright, that's done.
Alright.
What else?
Okay, I assumed that one.
That one just looks like mold.
Circuit board.
Alright, that is so efficient.
Like, it pays itself, man.
I know there's like videos of like fake repairs too I don't
okay I really okay like I know like everything is content
now but I hate like when um when content creators do like
fake cleaning or like you know how like like have you ever
seen those videos where they like dump a plushie or
something in like a drain and be like look at this plushie I
found left all alone we gotta clean it
um like it's like oh my god how could they do such a thing
to this item and it's like they did it like fake restoration
fake cleaning let's
see oh and i just screwed that in oh my god i keep
forgetting which one i've done and which one i haven't i'm
losing track i'm losing track of the sacred text Yeah, okay,
the carpet cleaning shit is so gross.
I can't watch those, actually.
Like, they're not, they're not, they're, like, chill,
though.
It's because, like, it's like, that's pee.
You know, when they start cleaning and you're like, that's
pee.
That's not relaxing the wash.
That's not, like, therapeutic or whatever the shit is.
All right, is this repair or what?
Or clean.
It's clean.
I have a bunch of parts for this.
Maybe I have some.
Yeah, so relaxing.
I don't think it's just P-Dokie.
I wonder what that's saying.
All right, that shit's fried.
Do I have?
I do not.
I use circuit board.
Oh, where is it?
It probably works.
I found it.
I mean, I could just buy it.
I can just buy the part, honestly.
Oh, and is it worth buying it?
Where's the Atari?
1,700.
Or do I take the gamble?
1,000.
Okay, four.
Four star.
What is this?
Three star.
Okay, I'll buy the four star.
People lie on the internet.
Remember, people lie on the internet.
All right.
Well, I'll just clean this for now.
You don't have to worry about it later.
Oh, this doesn't work.
Oh, joystick doesn't work.
Front panel doesn't work.
Okay, I know I have the front panel and the joystick.
Okay, everything's fine.
All right.
We'll leave that another day.
Worse, I would never.
Alright, what about you?
You are clean.
Alright, I mean, that...
Nice and efficient.
I got five reviews?
Wait, people review me?
Oh, shit.
Maybe I should have taken my time.
Wait, where are my reviews?
How do I know if I'm doing a good job?
Oh, shit.
Wait, they can review me.
Finally, my shift is over.
So I'm a real hairy.
I've got exams to my professor.
We fear his stuff.
Oh, shit.
It's like Uber.
Oh, no.
I don't, I know I don't talk to people in Uber.
So I don't have to see what my Uber rating is.
Honestly, I looked at it last time.
I was like, oh, it's not bad.
But it's like, obviously, it's not like 100%.
You know?
It's not like I'm, oh, I'm 4.75.
I think that's pretty decent.
I'm 4.75.
I just don't talk to anyone.
That's it.
4.75.
That's pretty good.
Oh, where's the other master?
Oh, never mind.
I hope you can help me.
Not bad.
I've stayed at five.
Sorry for five years, baby.
I shouldn't have told me that.
I'm going to, I will get on Uber.
I'll learn how, I'll relearn how to drive just so I can give
you one star.
I saw my phone.
It's almost new, but I dropped it.
And as it turns out, it's a rare auto rollout.
Limited edition.
It's really expensive.
I even found a buyer already.
How about I send a courier over later?
Oh, I got to run.
That's my bus.
What am I supposed to do?
150,000?
Oh, how?
What do you mean?
You've got to buy it.
Or 15,000?
Oh, for me?
Oh, it's for me.
Okay.
I was like, bro, you have a cracked screen.
Who's buying this?
Who the fuck is buying this from you?
I bought one for a thousand yen.
You know, she's getting scammed.
She's 100% getting scammed.
And that's the only broken part, right?
I just want to be sure.
Oh my god.
Why did I take all of this apart?
God, I'm so fucking stupid.
I did not need any of this.
Okay.
I was like, but what if, guys?
What if there's more at the bottom?
What if something else broke in the bottom?
I was just...
Oh my gosh, I should have kept everything.
I should have just saw the display and called it a day.
Why do I have to be so thorough?
Oh my god, okay.
Is that not where it goes?
Oh, that's where it goes.
I thought about, too.
I hesitated.
I was like, hmm.
to unscrew everything it's just literally just a display
screen she dropped it it wasn't that hard to shouldn't be
that hard to figure it out too i don't know where to look at
my reviews like am i efficient i can't tell okay oh nice i
got it well night delivery i'm right here Oh, the customer's
my hiring?
It's an envelope for you from her.
Payment for phone repairs?
Oh, she's planning on selling her.
Oh, he doesn't know.
I'm waiting for a call or email from her every evening.
I thought she hadn't worked out how to use it, but it turns
out she's just broken it.
Isn't that funny?
She's definitely, she'll definitely write.
Oh, maintain a agreeance.
support it's it's okay buddy gotta fight you'll find out
soon oh yeah the phone really works now thank you it's he'll
have to find out the hard way oh hey is that black mold is
that poor guy he doesn't know that poor guy okay i think
that's everything is everything yeah nothing's broken let's
just put all the parts in here all right i need to check i
need to know what my review i need oh i did it it wasn't
easy it was a whole adventure but i did it that's what
happened i was asking about the class an old lady thought
out yeah you okay sure you were and everybody stood up and
clapped guys blows of her handbag, I fell into the bushes.
I came out on the other side, and there was a dog that broke
its chain to get at me.
It was chasing me around like my backpack was full of meat.
It was terrifying.
Fortunately, the dog's owner stopped it just in time.
Well, after a couple bites, the owner was very happy to help
me trace that class, and that's how I found it.
And then everybody stood up and clapped.
The school turned out to be nearby.
The name was Yoi.
Of the girl, I mean.
I never seen anyone jump that hat to be honest she was just
so happy she caught me here and even gave me a gift so
beautiful you should oh the um for the job I did where I
scanned the child but you should have seen it I put it up
man I should have seen it guys I really should have how do I
know what my reviews are I have five reviews
what how What do I know?
What are my reviews?
I'll never know.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
All in.
You guys don't understand the PPP.
The PPP.
The PMP is going to go so hard.
Where do I put this, though?
Guys, it's going to pay itself.
Championship ended a couple hours ago, and the results are
out.
I came first.
You won't believe it.
around new joystick was what decided.
It's all because of you.
Thank you so much.
And it looks like things are going well for you too, right?
And congratulations on getting a Nokia P&P license.
As promised, I've got an order for you.
Can you fix it, please?
Alright.
Let's check this PPP out.
My PPP is broke.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, oh my god.
Is that the sky?
him oh man super bad you didn't have any games in your pvp
20k oh my i told you guys i told you it'll pay itself oh my
god no wonder this is 28k though this is too there's a lot
of screws it is with my new screws too oh my god are those
more screws and I just glue everything together
why don't we just have one big screw okay Wi-Fi panel sure
nothing's gonna go around with that just one giant screw
that everything just connects to surely there's nothing like
surely that'll be safe
all right it's over here all right let's see everything all
right now i gotta figure out how to put all this back
together i was not paying attention all right that i'm gonna
play a little puzzle game now eventually something will fit
guys so something will fit all right there you go
Okay, screw this.
Alright.
And then we screw that in.
See, I'm professional.
You can tell, because I can...
Where does this go?
Again, I'm a professional.
You can tell.
Oh.
And that here, and then bam!
Done!
all right put that in can't wait for my electric screwdriver
soon all right i see my ppp on the counter thank you so much
payment as usual by the way have you checked your ratings i
left a review if you don't have program review the ratings
i'll email you a link you really shouldn't install it oh my
god thank god finally it's so great that we have a new
master i was very sad when the old one went missing i i feel
like we should we should Like, what do you mean, missing?
Like, I feel like a missing person's case is very scary and
important.
Skydemono told me that he got involved with the wrong
people.
That definitely won't happen with me.
Draw Happy Pac-Man.
Oh, I'm going to draw Happy Pac-Man.
I think that's cute.
Whoa.
I installed the app.
All right, I hope there's no viruses on here.
Guys, you want to check out my new Minecraft mod?
the best repair shop in oh i got five stars nice i'm doing
good i should really start repairing the other stuff though
wait actually what was this i was missing on oh this is just
a clean okay wait this is the one that had missing stuff i
need a circuit board there you go i piece everything back
together
I should actually start my own repair shop.
Look at me, go!
Done.
There you go.
Alright, let's see.
Now for it is screwdriver now.
More bristle, less dust.
And a $55,000.
Hey there.
I work at the shop across...
Oh, it's my rival.
So you're the one to take over your own master's duty, huh?
I'll remember your face.
this box here the owner is gonna come and pick it up don't
even touch it it's a very fragile robot dog that even i was
able to fix properly hunt your neighbor will sort it out oh
so you'd be happy to hand the robot dog over to the bucket
oh it's the bucket man hard to buy these days and you'll
need less to steal it anyway even i had no chance and i'm
the acting akiba repair masters
I'm pretty important.
Well, you don't seem too impressed by this.
You must have never tried to use your hands for anything
more complex than tightening a couple of screws and dusting
the shelves.
Perhaps you could try to fix this then.
I find it in the marketplace.
The thing's so simple, even my niece could have done the
repair.
But I've been seeing her for a long time and have no time to
do this myself.
I'll take a look.
Well, I'll be watching you.
Okay.
Need it for brick game?
What the fuck is brick game?
Alright.
Apparently I need a license for this.
License for...
Oh, this.
Allows you to see...
Oh, okay.
I mean, I can just afford it.
Let's just buy it now.
Yay!
Okay, I need a license for this first.
Oh, shit.
It's just that easy.
I didn't learn how to actually do it.
I just bought it on the internet.
I'm back to bother you again.
Can I pick up my sick little friend?
Thank you so much for delivering him.
I really missed him.
It's too bad the last master went missing.
He got definitely fixed it.
What?
Who is this guy?
Like, like, could he fix fucking, can he fix the fucking
Tesla robots or some shit?
Is that why he went missing the government guy?
Got him?
It's a robot dog.
It's impossible to get a license for those at the moment.
So I'm all alone for now.
At least have my names.
Oh, speaking of that, please fix this in the meantime.
I had it delivered pretty recently, but it's already broken.
My hands are my worst enemies sometimes.
Thanks.
There's another Iodachi.
Alright, this can't be that hard to do.
My god, unscrew this.
Don't worry, I can fix him.
Okay, now what?
Okay.
Oh, there we go.
Got the battery out.
Yeah, this shit is dirty as hell.
I wonder if the niece never came back.
If the niece is only visiting you to get shit fixed, maybe
she doesn't love you.
She's just using you for your trade.
oh my god there's so many screws for this i feel like we
don't need six screws for this one giant screw in the middle
or four screws in the corner and bam you got it that's
efficiency right there all right what's broken buttons oh
it's just the buttons all right let's see oh he has five it
though uh fuck it i can afford it i'll buy this and then oh
hey nice thank you all right time to unscrew this now i just
need buttons yeah one giant screw to put everything together
the batteries work yeah the battery is silver the battery
stuff juicing them damn these are efficient batteries
I did not expect the batteries to still work.
Yeah, I'll just grab all the parts, too.
Alright.
I think they all work, too.
So I don't have to worry.
Alright, now...
This guy.
Alright, I just need to grab the buttons, and then it's
cleaning time.
Alright, what do I need cleaned?
Oh, shit, that's the broken buttons.
Back panel.
Boop.
We will give it a little good spray.
And then front panel battery.
All right.
Oh, I was going to say, where's the 1%?
All right, nice.
All right, now you got to remember how to piece everything
back together.
Okay, this button.
Whoa.
Oh, there.
I know what I'm doing, guys.
Where am I?
Okay.
Alright, motherboard.
Look at the puzzle.
I'm certified.
I bought my license on eBay.
I know what I'm doing.
Do you have an eBay license?
I don't think so.
I spent like 50 grand getting this.
license.
Yeah, if I click everything, eventually it'll work.
Alright, bam.
There we go.
Boop.
It's that easy.
Okay, I should really fix these orders, though.
He managed to fix it.
Sounds like a good job for a beginner, obviously.
Though, there's this.
And here, well, what else to expect from an amateur like
you?
I would have done a far better job.
At least I hope you didn't make things worse.
Does it even work or should I check it as well?
You didn't include new batteries?
Amateur.
I found some money inside.
You don't say.
That's unexpected.
Today's my day, apparently, or my week, or even my month.
Oh, you've got problems as well, then.
Nah, don't mind me.
Hi, mom.
Did he just, okay, not, you know what?
$9,000 to get chit-chalk.
That's fine.
I'll take that.
Look, if I got $9,000 just to, it's like a super chit- You
know, like, when people call you shit at a game and they
give you, like, an Akasupa for it, that's fine.
It's just like being a streamer.
It's fine.
9,000 yen just to be like...
You can talk like exactly if he's paying.
It's okay.
Jesus Christ.
Where the fuck did they find this?
I need to buy a new sprayer.
Okay.
Alright.
Done.
I'm just making up for the the the day the day the one day I
skipped a day accidentally I need to buy I need to buy
another air duster
I don't know if I should the smallest model automatically
cleans up the three parts okay I gotta save up for that shit
all right we gotta start saving money wait what's this oh
it's so many orders Oh my, 4.9.
Oh, are you serious?
That makes it worse.
It makes it worse because it's like from the guy that runs
the champion.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Okay, I could save my money, but I could get a seat in bass
though.
My average view average.
What a fucking hater.
It's worse because it comes from the...
Me, the guys that won the chat, that might as well be a one
star.
That might, oh my God, now I'm a hater.
Now, now I'm going to review bomb him.
I got to report this review.
Guys, four stars.
If you're not five stars, you might as well be nothing.
Good.
That's it.
I'm review bombing.
I think that's fine
Uh There we go Every shop meets a Maneki Neko Here's five
bucks to get one with Uh Griffin thank you for the super
chat Thank you, thank you, you're so right It's a classic
You know it's a good shop when it has one too Alright
Alright Oh my god, it's been two out.
This game has been really addicting so far.
Let's order one, honestly.
Now I'll start saving money.
Yeah.
Put him here.
I have more Zen now.
Okay, repair.
Is that the only thing that's broken?
No, that's definitely not the only thing that's broken.
What the fuck did you do to your phone?
Oh, I need to buy a new Pokia.
Pokia phone.
I wish there was a search bar for this.
Doesn't turn on.
Email is trying to...
I think it's fine.
He has good reviews.
It should be fine.
Oh, do I...
I'm going to check.
Just in case.
I think he just...
Maybe it looks dirty in the inside.
oh yeah whoops okay we definitely need new battery is there
anything else just a keyboard that's dirty that's fine all
right you'll put that here because i don't have the parts
for this guy yet all right i think i could take new orders
now all right egodachi egodachi all right here we go i'm
gonna buy an got you just in case whoa okay yes one star i
don't i was like whoa all right you know i feel like that
guy's gonna lie to me 100 that looks like a liar repair oh
shit what's wrong with this
all right what's wrong with this okay i need to get it
doesn't turn on works uh all right we're not could buy the
one star so we'll buy this guy all right what's wrong with
you all right burn circuit
board all right get these out of the way all right goodbye
oh my god why can't i okay there you go i was like why can't
i throw you away do i have a circuit board oh my god i do oh
fuck i spent money
It's fine.
Extra parts, you know.
It's all right.
Oh, and you have to really imagine I just sent it over.
Everything's fine.
I just didn't screw it in.
Picks up and everything falls apart.
And I'll be like, oh, I don't know what happened.
It must have been your fault.
I'm not clean.
Oh, my God.
There's a broken...
All right.
I was too efficient, guys.
I was too efficient that's my issue oh my god you know when
you're just too good at your job
okay what's in here all right oh yeah this is where I'm
missing stuff okay now this is where I have to clock in and
clock out I just wait what do I do I guess I'll take two
more orders What do I do?
I'll just take more orders.
That's what I'll do.
Spent money for no reason.
You mean we're just being toky-king.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How can I pass the time?
A closed door?
Is it just speedrun?
I'm back open?
Do I rush end date?
But it's like past 2 a.m.
Oh, no.
I don't know if it counts because it's past 2 a.m.
morning no i should have taken more orders oh wait what's
wrong with this i forgot about this one it was so tiny okay
all right what's wrong with this nothing yet
oh yeah no what the fuck happened did you got a sharpie and
says oh my god did you're fucking Did your fucking thing got
AIDS?
What is this?
Oh, it's up to...
Oh, it got burnt out.
Okay.
It's fine.
I have another one.
Oh, I need another screen lens, too.
He got AIDS or some shit.
What the fuck happened to your thing?
The LCD is just gone.
Okay.
Anything else dirty?
Yeah, we're just missing the screen lens.
Is that everything?
Yeah, it should be everything.
I should get rid of that, though.
Is this?
Okay, now my workshop is closed.
Well, gotta wait till...
Three hours, I guess.
I'm just gonna people watch.
I'm gonna people blob watch.
this game is pretty addicting i i think it's very i don't
know what's the word like um i didn't it doesn't feel like
i've been playing for two hours type deal
like i do lose track of time playing it very relaxing yeah
very satisfying
enjoying it just clicking all the buttons and pretending
like definitely pretending I know what I'm actually doing
you know what wait wait let me order food I should order
dinner now what time is a 7 yeah I should order dinner very
satisfying no the sandwich place I should order sandwich
place I actually wanted a sandwich but it closes after
before 7 hmm I don't want craving today am I craving today
what I eat yesterday I ate what did I eat what did I eat
today oh oh I remember I remember what I had an unihiri with
a hamburger steak I was like oh shit I'm still in the
Bahamas actually today I'm actually not feeling like Jolly
Beats today I did eat I did eat let's see I do I want to
sandwich, but like, like an Italian sandwich, but they don't
have.
I think all, they usually close early.
The one I like closed early.
Oh, okay.
There is this Italian sandwich place.
Not my favorite one.
I've had, I've had ordered from them before.
You know, I'll order from them again.
I do like it.
It's not my top favorite, but I do like what they, What they
have.
I'm ordering it.
Alright.
One more hour till delivery guys here.
Oh, wait.
They have dessert.
How many desserts do they have?
Oh, cano.
Oh, I get a tiramisu.
I'll get a tiramisu.
I've been at a tiramisu in a while.
Alright.
Ring ring.
Where's my delivery, man?
When was the last time I've slept in this game?
Should put this here, too.
Alright, let's see.
I have 10.
Oh, guys, I might have taken too many.
Whoops, I did.
I have 10 warriors.
Let's go.
It should be fine.
No longer available.
Bro, how the fuck am I supposed to learn how to repair robot
dogs?
Alright, here we go.
Okay.
So we don't need that.
Oh, shit.
A lot of things are broken right now, which is not ideal.
I need that electric screwdriver.
Okay, that's broken.
What is not broken here?
That's broken.
All right, let's put all of this here.
All right.
Where's the phone?
Is this the phone?
Okay, I need the battery front panel function buttons.
Okay, front panel, function button, option button.
Oh, that was one of the broken buttons, was it?
Ah, god damn it.
All right.
Okay, I need to buy another phone.
Do I have another one?
It works.
okay um it just I'll buy this one that's very okay this one
it just works guys very confident all
right yeah nothing's broken yet so far so good God these
screws are so fucking We need to zoom in for that.
Oh, every...
Oh, no.
I was like, oh, every...
Oh, nope.
Almost everything works.
Alright, that's fine.
I think I have all the parts I need now.
Okay, where is it?
Is this guy's part?
Yeah.
Alright, what do I need?
I need one fucking switch.
Yep, there we go.
Boom.
Fixed.
it works guys all right done but that's new all right that's
the tomagachi all right what's this all right what's wrong
with this clean and repair all right gotta buy oh I don't
have we I can buy a fucking PlayStation and nobody's selling
one so we gotta figure this out so it's okay i just need a
case
okay get rid of battery i feel like the more harder job is
just the jobs that are harder just has more screws nothing
else like the the more expensive products like the 10 000
plus is just every thousand every screw equals like one
thousand dollars
broken Jesus fucking great everything's you might just buy a
new one it's more expensive fixing this just buy a fucking
new one at this point
totally oh my god why do I I just buy new batteries why do I
need to clean the battery I just buy another battery you're
like what like like 100 yen or some shit To buy a new one.
I feel like it'd be cheaper to buy a new one at this point.
Okay, I need...
Motherboard.
Alright, parts.
Okay, how much is it?
Okay, motherboard.
Jesus Christ.
That this stuff... I'm... I'm putting you on standby until
someone sells anything.
Igodachi.
what's this one I need more another phone okay do they have
another phone oh
I'm gonna buy this all right this guy clean okay that one's
easy just a cleaning job these batteries have sentimental
value my dad gave me those batteries before he died how
could you dokey you have no empathy he gave those batteries
to me before the war
okay all right let's see Back panel.
Yeah, that looked Fucking dirty as hell.
Oh no, now I have to use my hands Like the fucking pleb
Alright.
Piece all of this together.
And they're vintage batteries.
They were made before I was born!
How dare you suggest Using new batteries?
There we go.
Good as new.
All right, the PMP.
I was just cleaning, that's fine.
I'm trying to...
I'm just like...
I clean it with my hands like a goddamn peasant.
I bet the master repairman doesn't have to clean it with his
hands.
I bet it's fully off.
automated.
But he had the fucking electric cleaner.
I feel like the electric screwdriver is like the investment
here.
Okay, I know like everything.
I just, I don't know.
I just thought maybe, maybe it's dirtier on the other side.
I was like thinking, hmm, should I unpiece everything there?
Okay.
Monterboard.
The full disassembly.
And he cleans up his fucking mind.
He's like, clean!
God, he's so cool.
I wish I was like him.
Okay, battery land.
Alright.
Something will fit in here.
There we go.
Oh, there's...
Uh.
Um.
What else can I?
Oh, there we go.
It's just that easy.
I have a license, by the way, to fix this.
Yeah, I bought my license off of eBay.
How did you know?
On eBay, Alamadr.
Alright, done.
7,000.
Okay, what's wrong with this?
It's clean.
Alright, I feel like...
Okay, never mind.
I was going to say, you can do this yourself, but that's not
how I'm going to make money.
I hope they never learn how to do this themselves.
Easy 5K.
Oh my god, please.
oh my god what else okay is this i was like what else is
holding it back
i just need to clean this one part that was at the bottom
okay what else is dirty front panel
all right and then back panel now i'm thinking like a hatty
man Exactly.
They don't need to know how to do it.
I'll keep the business going, you know?
Um...
There we go.
Trial and error.
What?
Am I... Am I screwing this?
I'm screwing this in.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, there you go.
I'm a professional.
Alright, what's this?
I'm just gonna... Actually, I'm gonna put all of this here
for now.
Because I'm like...
I need to figure out how to repair the stuff I need to
repair.
I need to order to repair stuff just before it's too late.
Oh, it's a bird screen.
Oh my god.
I think that's actually what I need to.
okay this is oh my god please okay this is I need repair
that this is the cell okay this is repair this is to sell
this one is to sell I have two I forgot I buy a lot all
right so this one this is to repair this is to repair okay
repair i'm lost track repair this is to repair so i need to
buy game boy you have another game boy in stock it works
okay 5 000 is there another one all right gosh no okay i'm
gonna buy this for now and hope i get it back in time all
right nice all right this one clean okay this is a cleaning
service i want parts in advance just to be safe okay is this
clean or repair clean and repair okay what about this clean
all right
oh shit okay give me a okay uh buy this just in case all
right
another game boy and then i also have this all right so i'll
do i have too many things now okay uh is this repair this is
screen lens okay i need a screen lens oh shit where did i
put all right there you go okay this is fine
okay we can be efficient here just need a lens i just need
the lens oh please tell me the lens still works oh thank god
okay that's all we need it's this in the trash there we go
uh fuck which one was i working on which i'm this is a don't
worry it's efficiency is it this guy oh shit it's not that
guy is it you oh it's you we're very efficient what we do
okay now i fixed it
yeah the battery goes here and then bobbing bob boom done
yeah my i'm very organized system guys it's very organized i
know where everything is Thanks, Bunches, for fixing it.
I bet it works better than before now.
I love playing my favorite game so much.
Sorry to ask him, but I just really miss my robot dog.
He's been my only...
What do...
I don't even have a license.
You want me to illegally fix your dog?
I'm sure you're not interested in it, but there's a chance
you can...
I'm fucking not even on sale.
Right, that you've heard it's hard to get right now.
Remember how's that winning the next repair Oh, just that
easy.
Get you that license.
If I can find any information about it, I'll email you for
sure.
Sorry for bothering you.
Thank you so much for your help.
All right, tug the rope.
I guess I got money at least.
Okay, do I have a part?
I don't even remember anymore my system.
My very organized system.
Okay.
It's very obvious.
I know where everything is.
Okay, it's a Doki system.
It's a Doki filing system.
I don't know what part is actually broken.
Like every part seems usable.
Oh, and nothing was broken there.
There we go.
Last day.
Was I missing battery and option button?
Okay.
Fuck was the battery did it okay.
There you go.
I was like did not come with a goddamn battery
Guys trust the system guys my very organized system where I
know where everything definitely is Oh, hello.
Oh, it's a foreigner.
Ohio goes I must Matsuda Akibas like shikoi this I did not
do okay
many photos of my trusty camera here.
But I actually took the wrong corner and there was a bunch
of really good at Japanese, though.
I assume he's speaking Japanese to me.
Real tough people.
All tattooed head to toe, just like in those Yakuza movies.
They were connecting some electronic devices to electricity
wires.
And lights went off as a split for a split second, just like
this.
I blinked it.
Whoa!
Suddenly they're running after me.
It's a weep.
Clearly intent on giving me a beating.
So I dropped my new camera right there and ran away for my
life.
Never found it again.
Went back to the hotel to rest and well, clear my head.
So I turned on the...
Guys, okay.
I wait for you at a big cafe nearby.
Can't wait.
Is this me?
Can't wait to have my milkshake served by a girl with this
Nekomimi.
Oh yeah, she's in Japan right now, right?
Shigoi, thank you, Matsuda.
All right, I need to check my license.
Okay, the controller.
Okay, I need to get a license.
How much is the license for this?
Uh, ZBOP controller.
A 33,000?
Oh, my God, 30k.
Really?
I can clean this for now.
All right, we'll just clean this for now for the extra
money.
I think that's literally the only thing that's dirty.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh my god, I'm gonna clean it with my hands.
Oh my god, it's so much work.
I forgot how spoiled I was.
Is it clean now?
So clean.
I'm done something's not right what do you mean by clean all
of it what else do I need a clean oh maybe that thing over
here but it's so clean though that has to be the only thing
left how would they know if it's not clean they don't know
even know how to open it up.
Do you see the exterior isn't clean?
I'm just trying to be efficient, guys.
You think they'll know how to open this up?
If they do, they wouldn't need me.
They wouldn't need to pay me to do this.
Oh, my God, Sonny.
That's fucking...
Fine.
Oh, maybe it's... No, it's not this.
Okay, what?
Oh, my God.
God, it's all the way.
Oh my, that's how they get you.
That's how they fucking get you.
Okay, now I know it's all clean.
Swear to God.
Okay.
Alright.
So much for efficiency.
They fucked with me first.
It's a trick.
They put it the very back at the very last part.
Like, what the fuck was I supposed to do?
Okay.
Oh my god, what's wrong with this?
Okay, I need another...
I buy another Igodachi apparently, an old...
Okay.
You know what?
Fuck it.
It's one star, but like...
Maybe it'll be okay.
Okay, I need to grab the parts.
Uh...
I mean, the battery still works.
Thank god.
Okay, get this out of the way.
God, I know.
The moment I have it, I'm saving enough for the electric
screwdriver.
The guy comes over, their parents fucking Xbox controller.
Where are you going to do?
You're too busy at the maid cafe.
What do you need?
He's at a maid cafe.
Does he really need an Xbox controller at the maid cafe?
Like, what is he going to do?
Okay, I think this was the controller.
What do I need?
Motherboard buttons, control panel, back panel.
Okay, motherboard, control board.
I have double control.
Yeah, control board, buttons, back panel.
Buttons, back panel.
All right, let's get this started.
Nothing's dirty, right?
Nothing's dirty.
I spent so long since I repaired this.
I don't fucking know.
Uh.
Um.
Yes.
What do I?
What else?
Okay, there it is.
That's like, where does the green part go?
I got, where's my YouTube video?
Play Halo with the maids.
Yeah, he brought his Xbox.
Good.
Screw this up.
There we go.
Done.
Alright, what else?
I don't start...
Yeah, I don't have anything.
I just need to deconstruct this then.
Start gathering stockpiling parts.
Alright.
And...
Give me that...
Oh.
wait i forgot about you all right let's see what's wrong
with you just clean thank god
oh my god how would you get dust in here how would you get
dust in here oh my god it was in the fucking time capsule it
was in a 20-year cap time capsule or some
shit how did you up the entire equipment
yeah he was in he was in the desert playing tomagachi
All right.
That thing was buried.
The mom buried the...
The mom had enough and buried the Tamagotchi in the
backyard.
She couldn't feed him every 30 minutes.
She had enough.
Okay.
Done.
Boop.
All right, I could take more orders.
uh look it give me all the orders above a really good
reviews right now the repair master gets free robo repair
license as a reward so there's one few ways to lay your
hands except for the old master i guess i'm still trying to
find more info on how do you actually participate okay so
you didn't do anything for me yay i have so many good
reviews guys i'm doing it.
Okay, let's do this one, too.
I mean, it's just small things.
We're stockpiling parts right now.
Just trying to be efficient.
We all know.
Efficient dokeybird.
Well known for efficiency.
Alright.
I have enough for the... Oh, I literally just need $1,000.
Like, come on!
pay me already I need a thousand dollars I could fix this
guys goddamn Xbox controller oh
my god oh wait this guy oh my god forgot about you where did
this controller come from I oh shit I left it on the shelf
that's fried for real I was Like, where did he come from?
Holy shit.
Now, this was in a sandstorm.
Just try to play on the Atari.
Put it in the archaeology hunt or some shit.
Alright.
I told you I have a system.
You just don't understand.
You're just not.
You don't have the brain IQ to understand it.
It's like Rick and Morty.
You gotta be this smart to understand my system.
Okay.
Uh, wait.
Is that broke?
Okay, no.
Okay.
record there you go all right done all right should have
enough now okay now i have enough for the license um what
was the light xbox controller all right nice
okay this is the dec okay deconstruction is here uh this is
a job job job okay let's see what do i need to do for this
clean okay clean okay clean guys the system is working clean
clean okay what's this clean oh shit everyone knows i'm the
best cleaner for a repair shop all right clean they're all
just clean jobs nice okay clean oh my god easiest 10k of my
life oh my god i'm fucking scamming these poor folks all
right then my xbox controller license okay repair all right
i'm gonna buy another controller oh i just don't need it all
right let's just assume the reviews are bad but let's just
assume they
need they heard about my titan brush hey it's not about the
size it's about the motion of the bread of the bristles okay
he knew that bro what the fuck is wrong with okay i think
that's the only thing that's wrong with it oh my god there's
so little screws oh never mind
damn right so how you use those bristles guys the one needs
to be clean left and right alright time to get the gamer
gunk off
oh my god how did it get it under there
directional buttons I think that's everything alright just
need the need the this i need the covers for that this
part is broke that's the part i need what do you mean it's
broken that's the exact part i need okay how much is it 2000
how much do i get oh 11 000 fuck i actually need that part
too
I don't know.
Is it worth buying the back panel, guys?
I don't think it is.
Oh, my gosh.
Such tiny screws.
2.8k yen, guys.
It's yen.
Don't worry.
I know.
It's yen.
Yeah, do not.
Don't need to start a riot.
I got all the screws off.
Yeah.
We'll just start assembling it, I guess.
okay i'm just missing the i'm literally just missing the
back panel so it should be fine
there you go almost done with it with this job just start
cleaning until someone puts another controller it's an xbox
controller where are they like
I have another controller at this point.
Yeah.
Every time I get close to an electric screwdriver, they
fucking take it away from me.
Alright.
Time to dust it with my tiny brush.
Time to dust the batteries from the guy's dead dad that he
gave him before he passed away.
That's it.
Everything.
Everything's clean now.
Oh.
Screw screws.
Lefty loosey.
Righty tidy.
God, I can't wait.
It's going to be so fast when I have the electric
screwdriver.
It's going to be so efficient, guys.
Just you wait.
It's going to be so efficient.
Anyone put it up yet?
Oh!
I'm buying it.
I can't wait.
I'm not patient enough.
I want to get this guy's goddamn...
I want to get this guy's controller out of here.
There we go.
I can't wait.
I need that 11k now.
Well, technically 10k.
Boom.
There you go, now I can go back to cleaning.
Thank you, Masuda.
The controller looks brand new, Segoi.
You are a real wizardroodosama.
I'm so...
Sorry.
Okay, that got me.
I'm so happy, really, by the way.
Masuda, I'll tell you that match to fix the heart as well.
Wizardroodosama.
I'm in the most beautiful hostess at the maid cafe It's oh
it's hiring Oh no drama
He's just like me for real I should give him the tourist tax
You remember the I guess heard about the tourist tax Where
like you could get charged more if you speak English
It made my main most mouth outfit was just like in my
favorite ad Hawaii, my heart's still going doki-dokie.
She was close by all the time, always smiling.
She even drew a Neko emoji with some ketchup on my Omurais.
And she also gave me her number!
Oh wait, what about the number I got?
Wait, I never called it.
Told me that she would show me the real Akihabara to me.
You're a skeptic, huh?
I'll show it to you.
Wait, where's my Pokia?
I can't find my phone.
Anyway, how do these numbers in there?
left at the maid cafe.
Thank you for everything.
Matsuda, I must go back like a proper gentleman.
I shall not lose your number, my dear Haru Yi.
Oh, I tell him to be more careful.
Is that the post office?
The post guy's fucking girlfriend?
That was the guy's girlfriend.
I don't, bro, bro, I don't think she's in that.
Bro, you're getting scammed, bro.
She has a boyfriend.
I mean, does does actually does she know she has a boyfriend
i'm a little skeptical now holy what did this guy do to his
thing wait is there like a story on how they it's dirty like
i'm curious i i just accept orders i don't know if there's
like an actual story whenever i accept the orders on the
emails does it tell me how they fucked up their shit no they
didn't please fix if you can Okay, some of them do.
I was just like, what did you do to this?
Like, this was definitely in a time.
Like, were you there for Pompeii?
This was in an active volcano eruption.
Back in, ah, yes.
Pompeii, where they played on the Atari.
Oh, no, that's definitely dirty.
dropped in the litter box I'll make sure everything's clean
now
Alright, nice Oh, hello Hi, Mass, I'm beat Oh, well, there
was this tourist in the cafe Yelling, Kauai, Kauai And
Shagoi At all the mates Asking them for a number and driving
everyone nuts I gave him the number of pizza place Now that
I'm thinking about it That Yamada Korea seems so quiet and
polite Oh He did not know.
He does.
She doesn't know she has a boyfriend.
She.
Keep his.
Oh.
This.
Leave her in the streets, guys.
Oh.
She.
She's a skink.
Oh.
No.
The drama.
Oh no, I super accidentally spilled a beer on it, fell on
the floor.
Treshes for the streets.
I even found a buyer for it already.
Thanks, Master.
Got it.
Yep, your phone.
A $10,000 is $10,000, guys.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
$10,000 is $10,000.
The maid streets.
Hey, money is money.
I gotta make business here.
I don't discriminate.
Hey, when it leaves, look, I just repair stuff.
I don't care who owns what.
Alright, I need a circuit board.
I have one of those, right?
I have a circuit board, actually.
I do.
Okay.
And then I need a speaker.
Speaker, battery, and battery.
There we go.
God, I stocked up on stockpile and all my parts, guys.
This is a Memphis manufacturing.
10k yen.
It's 10k yen.
Hope she makes sure to wipe the phone before she sells it.
Alright, there we go.
Alright, how are we?
Use your phone.
Your phone.
Hi, I'm here for the Pokia.
Is it done?
Oh, awesome.
My boss is a total monster.
She flipped out on me about it.
Can't do anything right in her eyes.
At least I can get a good price for this Pokia.
I almost forgot I brought you something.
Check it out.
You're priced from all kinds of devices.
Take them as a thanks on top of your payment.
It's my dream to compete in a repair master competition.
I spend my free time after work.
in school taking apart whatever gadgets i can oh gosh she's
so into me guys oh my god she wasn't into all those other
guys but i'm different i'm so different i can find a
practice on there always parts left over so many parts i
brought boxes like this over to the old master every morning
he paid me 2 000 a week upside me oh what a steal 4k oh my
god Say you'll do it.
Say you don't think guys I can fix it guys I I'm not like
the other repair guys guys oh my god a 4,000 a week
Please get that back Guys, do I do it?
She's the part of the street she is.
What's one more bill?
She's so right.
You know, I can do another one.
She doubled the price because I'm special.
I'm her special repair guy.
So, of course, she doubled the price.
I'm going to do it.
Oh, also, are you thinking of trying to enter the repair?
I can fix her, guys.
I can fix it.
She can fix me.
whoever wins usually end up getting a ton of customers and
then well i can sell my devices through you say you don't
know how to enter ask kashimoto here's what i do if you
manage to win the competition i'll bring you parts for free
if you promise to teach me the trade good luck gotta go oh
my god look at that i made money gosh she gave me two items
for 4k oh my god what a steal
oh my god you mean i get all that for 4k wow what a fucking
steal yes oh shit i got paid my bills i forgot about that
part okay what do i need here this is clean okay clean this
is clean and repair do i have an apartment for this okay
what's this clean okay this is clean this one is repair you
have a loose tongue i expected more from you that story
about my tongue my son was for your ears not the police oh
also he's gonna come by later but that's on the past and we
need to focus on things now you see i'm the organizer of an
expo, a big competition for repair masters, but the idiot
that workspring broke my only means of communication.
They're a bunch of headless chickens without me.
Well, technically, I dropped it, but it was their fault.
Always noisy, full of questions, getting in the way, I need
a fixed pronto.
I mean, that can't be too bad.
I can do it.
I got some cool parts from my new girlfriend, guys.
She's so into me.
I'm different.
don't tell anyone this also you look pretty beat try and get
some more sleep a dead master's not much good to me you too
huh i don't have time for this i'll figure out later see you
have i have i slept yet yeah oh my god the moment i every
time every time i get close okay auto roll up
Every time I'm close.
This one is clean.
Do not give to the siren.
But she's so hot.
Guys, you'll understand.
guys you you do the same thing don't lie to me you do the
same thing okay my license all right it's just mostly clean
let me fix this real quick oh it's also clean all right it's
not too bad
um anything else i can oh it's right here I see I told you
one big screw that's all you need just one oh never mind
there's some tiny screws
that's it I'm fucking I'm buying I'm buying this
where is it give me that I can't do this anymore
is that everything oh my god it's not everything What am I
missing?
Okay, there we go.
All right, what else is dirty?
Casing and battery.
Now I'll do the little dust for the finishing touches.
This is...
All right, there.
Now I need four?
Oh, it's up here.
And then the battery.
All right, and then...
There we go.
All right, now I gotta figure out...
I'll put all of this together.
Uh...
Every time.
Every time I get close to a... To a 50k.
Every fucking time.
How the fuck do I?
Um...
Okay, there.
There we go.
I know that is...
I mean, uh...
definitely know where that is
I had to put this on first like what the fuck I know this is
here
oh my god the zoom out oh my they're like it's too close
alright what oh the big screw the giant screw I forgot about
it 13k I'll do a repair I'll do some clean Okay, is there
any...
Looks like it's all set.
Here's the cash.
Now you can pay the rent you owe me.
Stupid expo.
Stupid competition.
Nothing but noise.
Oh yeah.
Um...
Can you help me get a robot dog license?
I heard that's a hard license to get.
But I cut a sponsorship deal with the manufacturer.
They said they gave a license to the next repairmaster
competition winner.
Do you even know what you're asking?
It's not you can just walk in and...
I can?
But I've been doing such a good job.
your name you have no i have like um i'm technically have
4.9 star reviews you don't even have a soldering iron you
should buy one first but um i would love to if i didn't
spend all my money on your fucking license that's it i'll
send my electrician by help you figure out your light
situation plus help you get soldering iron his contacts in
that area plus you can install your meter i forgot you don't
have one my meter what's that what do you mean meter what's
that oh man clearly I have so much to learn about the repair
business what do you mean by meter I have everything I need
but yeah more bills to pay you mean there's more stuff I
need a meter for what
okay what else is dirty what else is dirty.
Oop.
Alright.
Is there anything up this part?
Now for the time.
The time ones I'll use my brush.
I'll have to waste that here.
I think that's done.
What's the meter with you?
Oh.
It's been so long since I've done this.
Done a phone.
It's like back here.
What the fuck?
I don't fucking know.
I guess?
Oh, I know what I'm doing.
There we go.
And screw.
Nice.
Yay!
Alright.
Oop.
Alright, order will be collected tomorrow morning.
All of this is cleaning jobs.
I'm going to do the repair stuff.
A pair of gives me more money, too.
At least I know what to order later.
I'm going to put that here.
Okay, it's got new batteries.
What's fucking wrong with this?
Is it that?
I don't know if that's dirty or if it's burnt out.
What is wrong with it?
Everything seems fine so far.
Oh, it's the battery.
It's the fucking, it is the battery.
How do you break a battery?
Okay, it's literally, okay, end the screen.
Okay, at least, yeah, the screen makes sense.
Where is it?
Where the apple is there?
Is that not?
Oh, it's dirty.
Oh, it's the buttons.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
I need to buy another one.
All right.
I need...
Has anyone else broke there?
God damn it.
No one else has broke their thing.
Um, I guess I'll just buy a part.
It can't be that bad.
It is a brick game.
And I need buttons.
Oh yeah, it's 230 yen.
That's fine.
Alright, sorry.
My food was here.
230 yen.
It's fine, guys.
Okay, battery screen.
Battery compartment.
Alright.
and that needs cleaning got my spray here oh my god all
right there you know what else control board it tiny one
gets a tiny brush battery screen
and then dirty ass battery i'm gonna get my fortune i can't
put anything in here uh put this in here for now i'll screw
stuff in for now and then there's cleaning tab all right
that's it that's the only repair stuff everything else is
clean just a maid right
tanya's tanya screw
Jesus Christ I don't even want to know what they did to it
There we go Oh my god This was like It was buried
underground or some shit I think I brought my air duster
Alright nice One done Twenty more to go
okay next god why am i not making enough to automate this
every time i get close to automating i have to get another
license that's how they get you in this business you're
every time you make just enough money to make it efficient
new license or we'll arrest you.
I'm like, please please, sir.
That's all I have.
That's all my money.
I just want an electric screwdriver.
I don't even ask for much.
Like just one screwdriver that costs 55,000 yen.
Oh my god, this electric screwdriver is like plated and gold
or some shit
Oh, yeah, no, honestly, very realistic
Very, very realistic, sorry, I had to call again I think the
elevator expired for them Where is that?
How is it broken?
Oh, I bought this That's why God's gonna say, how is it
broken?
Oh my God, why did I buy this?
Maybe I should have listed the one-star review.
But I have to buy it right away.
You don't understand.
It was so worth it.
This is the reason why the other owner disappeared.
Oh my God.
he was just tired of buying license over and over again the
grind never stops
every time he thought he was like he was the master builder
they invent a new item to fucking repair
the big brush and the auto screwdriver man i wish i would
know how that feels i I wish I had Damn, inflation's hitting
hard right now I wish I know how that feels The feel of
life-changing screwdriver Must be nice
Yeah Time might get close every time I get close to it
oh i didn't finish the one last screw one last job all right
i should be here any moment now to collect all of this oh my
gosh yay all right oh what does he have oh oh these are my
parts that i need all right literally the one part i need
and now i'm done oh somebody ringing ding ding Don't worry,
Doki, we like you and your tiny brush just as you are.
Thank you.
At least someone likes my tiny brush.
What's the one screw am I missing right now?
There it is.
Done.
The lights are flickering again.
It seems like I'm just, oh wow, just when I made just enough
money to almost buy it.
electric screwdriver you're the youngest master around here
i must say that's where the legs the problem is that your
stupid expo your stupid competition use way too much energy
all this new tech uh your electric soldering eyes your
sandblaster a true real master use their hands only they're
preventing me that i have obligation i have to use my hands
you know back in my day in 1973.
I'll listen to what he says.
Junior is that huge brand new electronics store is opening
1973.
They turn on lights and boom.
Oh, Akiyabara goes dark for a solid three hours.
Can you imagine?
Well, you're probably too young to remember it anyway.
So right, it's my favorite gaming console.
A real engineer miracle.
None of these fancy new disc lasers or whatever sci-fi
things you kids are into nowadays.
Please fix it, Master.
install the energy meter and take oh is that another
license?
I swear to god so it's cheap and snappy renovations this
Hashimoto guy say Hashimoto mentioned something about your
soldering iron well are you really that serious about the
whole thing?
Meh fine I can try and talk to my friends they can probably
get you in do finish your pair of hand while I'm busy right?
Alright okay guys wait I think I have a license for this
wait guys I think I might have guys I have a like guys Oh my
god, I have a license for this Oh my god Something I
actually, I swear to At least I'm not repairing a PC right
now I'm worried of how much a PC license will cost me
Hey Doki, my partner forgot about me Because he's too busy
watching the stream Can you call him for me?
Hey, hey Pick up her call
Or you can both watch the stream together
Yeah, busted
Or why not just watch You guys both watch this stream
Alright, let's get this out of the way I think that's fine,
yeah I think everything else is clean, right?
Just to switch in the front For an old panel.
Alright, let's see.
I'll clean this then.
Oh my god, I'm so close to electric chair.
Whatever the fuck it's called.
Yeah, Doki and Chill, for real.
Invite me if there's a baby.
Invite me to the baby shower later.
Alright, here we go.
Name it after me.
I did that.
Wait, this one of the switches dirty.
Which one is it?
All right, let's see.
Oh my god, oh my god, I can't, I can't see the last.
Oh, what do I do?
I fucked up.
The switch is literally right under, oh no, I fucked up.
How do I get it?
I'm gonna have to, I'm just gonna grab this one.
The switch is literally right under it.
I can't get to it.
It's alright.
Modern solutions.
Alright.
Can I fit this?
What am I always the fucking flower?
The efficiency.
Nice.
Perfect.
Oh, don't forget to remove where it is i can't i want to
remove it okay it's apart it's like underneath it
oh my god it's right there do you guys see it's like right
oh my god it's right here
efficiency right efficiency guys It looks brand new, and
I've been busy fixing the wiring and installing the energy
meter.
Electricity fees are fixed.
By the way, it's 1,500 yen a week, and a courier will
deliver the actual bill to your door.
Do you really think it was free?
To be fair, the local network's dead like half the time, so
it probably shouldn't be.
Yeah, no shit.
Made some calls.
They told me it'll be available at your shop soon.
But here, my vice master, you shouldn't get one.
These things are the reasons.
The Akiba electricity network is so unstable these days.
There's that one fancy model everyone's selling is it's
defective comes from the factory like that Can't believe you
repair people still pay for these inferior things But well
everyone has to hone their soldering skills for the
competition Honestly this competition is nothing but a
circus nowadays Back in 1983 the winner got a free Hitachi
factory tour And now the grand prize is a license to do to
repair a robot dog Who even needs something like this a
robot dog really kids these days yeah the prize is yay more
oh my god i can finally afford it oh my god wait oh shit
license wait i can finally oh my god the electric
screwdriver that's all i need i can't afford my i'm 19 yen
oh i hope i don't have any bills to pay later i It's finally
here.
At last, the promised land.
Watch this.
Oh, my God.
No longer do I live in the stone age.
I'm so efficient.
oh my god no longer live in the stone age guys this is pure
efficiency now i i've lost track on what i've screwed and
what i haven't unscrewed guys i'm so efficient that i
actually don't know too efficient
wait what can i get How do I unpiece this?
I don't...
There you go, Tesla.
There you go, I found out.
I'm too efficient, guys.
I'm cursed with the efficiency.
What else is...
Oh, here it is.
Okay.
I was just too efficient, guys.
I know he is...
Just so much...
So much to take in.
Okay.
Hey, what else needs it?
Motherboard control panel.
Where's that?
Hello?
Oh, shit.
That's Yakuza.
Allow me to offer my respect, Master.
My name is Kaito from the Hashimoto family.
I believe you know my father.
I'm here to negotiate regarding incident involving a police
officer.
My father has placed me in charge of household operation.
Oh, it's like that show.
The show where the...
Like the husband is like a...
Yeah, the house I was thinking about that.
The Hashimoto family state, the windows, the floor,
bathroom, kitchen.
My orders are to bring order and cleanliness to the whole
place.
But what do I see?
A traitor right in front of me.
Well, Kelo, do you find yourself shaking?
This is your hour of reckoning where true master will deal
with you.
Scale and rust have eaten away at you from the inside.
Your fatal mistake was interrupting our morning ritual.
Put an end to it, master.
Ensure there are no witnesses.
I will be checking.
Oh, okay.
He just wants me to fix the kettle.
Eh, I'll fix it.
Oh, my God.
Do I need a license for this?
Oh, I don't.
Thank God.
I don't.
Thank fucking God.
Okay.
I don't need a light.
Okay, let me fix this first.
And then I'll deal with.
And then you can kill me later.
I like 19 yen.
I need some form of money right now.
Good.
Alright.
Oh, there.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
This is, like, actually game-changing.
This is here.
Oh, my God.
This is so many screws.
Where do they all go?
Okay.
Oh.
no what do i is there are they all in i get i think they're
all in all right there you go so efficient i know what i'm
doing please i need give me that money please i'm i'm so
broke okay there you go i don't have to worry as much now oh
last day okay we gotta fix this then
okay oh shit all right let's see what needs cleaning screen
lens
screen lens back panel
uh what else front panel oh yeah definitely for sure yeah
that's not a color anymore
okay that needs cleaning
and that should be it
And then...
What the fuck is it?
Wait, wait, what?
Uh...
Oh, that old...
Pure efficiency.
Trial and error.
That's what you'd like to see.
New repair, man.
Yeah, I think I'm going to be a master builder soon.
Alright, we're done with that.
I should take some more orders right now.
And then...
Oh yeah, I should fix the kettle.
Okay, or he's going to fucking kill me.
Alright, clean.
That's not too bad.
Now, how do I unpiece this?
Did I do it?
Oh, yeah, I'd make sure to check that or there would be
lizards in there.
Okay.
That's what I'll use this for.
Make sure you check the bottom of that.
You don't want fried lizards.
holy shit how do i clean this all right maybe you should put
water in there you're not maybe
i feel like there shouldn't be no way to dust and die if
you're using if you're putting water in there like i i don't
know i feel like we're losing the story here or like soak
some yeah like put anything any liquid
kid all right done baby went out my money being a house
husband's no laughing matter master more like a covert
operation my father is training my disciplines improve my
willpower in spite of this kettle understands that I see
that his conscience is clear now, Master.
Commitable work.
Here's your payment.
Speaking of, I have heard that your business...
It is?
Where did you hear that?
I've heard that your business is expanding, which is
delightful, but the taller the tree, the harder the wind
shake.
This is the first time I've heard about that.
The tree requires support to keep it from snapping.
A thousand... Oh, now I have to pay for protection.
Alright.
I...
I don't know how I'm expanding.
I'm still one person doing all of this, but alright.
Say that you're...
already paying rent and utilities at like no other not the
one who made the rules master everyone has someone above
them whether it be a boss or a god best not to anger those
at top where they're quick to bestow punishment a personal
favor to ask my housekeeping budget is limited as part of my
training i heard that you plan to enter a competition a
favorable bet would do so much for me one moment my patron
what clearly selling the china shop today ceramic pots are
half up we'll of family affairs they cannot wait i need a
hurry all right i made nine thousand dollars i made eight
thousand dollars all right all right this is repair or clean
clean what a deal but these are like ones i need repair
instantly or clean and repair all right clean and repair
clean Oh, this.
Clean and repair.
I can buy another...
I need to buy another walkie-talkie then.
12,000?
Fuck no.
I just want to fucking find this.
Alright, what's this?
Clean and repair.
Okay.
What we'll do...
We'll finish up these two.
Because it might be...
end of the day soon for these guys
bro i don't fucking i guess
all right gotta get these tiny off
all right menu memory slot front panel
yeah memory and then this oh What is this?
Oh.
What of this?
I can't tell they all look like his ass gamer gunk on it.
They all look dirty to me.
It's an Xbox controller.
He'd never be too safe.
Right here.
Oh, there it is.
and then there you go nice easy all right then we have the
phone
god i can't i should buy the big brush you guys said it's
really good and the soldering iron too how much money do i
have i've not been paying attention to my profits right I
feel like every time I make I stop paying attention because
every time I make money, even like just a little bit of
money, they come in and take it from me.
I've accepted my fate.
Every time I feel like I'm making money, it's gone.
And it's gone.
Where did I put the option?
This is the option button.
That's life.
First time.
Okay.
Bam, there we go.
This one, I need to deconstruct this.
You're fine.
Oh.
Oh my god, how do I...
I keep screwing and unscrewing.
How do I...
Oh, there you go.
You're fine.
Oh, there's nothing too bad going on with this guy.
Okay.
wait what it works just fine he had one star what was wrong
with him all the parts work
see guys reviews live maybe it was a new seller you know me
that's why He was a new seller.
Volume knob.
He over tried.
Yeah, maybe he got review bomb.
I was gonna say, like, nothing was wrong with his shit.
Casing battery.
Volume knob.
Yeah, that's everything.
Speaker.
Hey, what else?
Frequency knob, this tiny little thing.
uh tana oh yeah that definitely looks like it's been through
shit actual shit um audio jack that should be everything how
much money actually i'm gonna look 20 yeah nothing i don't i
can't afford anything oh circuit board all
right let's put everything back together
that um oh there we go it's that easy
boom it's very relaxing i like this game like i i almost
played it for four hours already so then the very relaxing
game plot's been interesting too but honestly i could just
do this all day
yeah i need pack panel and uh oh i need another circuit
board oh i do have a circuit board nice oh and a cord
luckily i have all of that everything else is just dirty
okay i don't know i should invest in a in a soldering iron
now or if i should buy a big brush i'll buy a big brush for
now i feel like yeah definitely i highly recommend this game
it's been pretty fun i know i'll do a part two on i don't
know i don't know i don't know maybe i should look up how
long to beat this game because like to see the ending of the
plot i feel like i played this for a while.
What do I need?
Okay, cleaning repair.
Oh, definitely need a new battery and a new backing.
That shit's dead.
Yep.
Alright, keyboard cover, antenna housing, battery back
panel.
Battery back.
Oh.
What?
What do I have right here?
Oh, do I not have another?
Oh, oh, wait, that's broken.
Front panel.
Oh, I'm literally missing a back panel.
God damn, I have to order another one.
Something my dad's.
6,200.
That's a scam.
That, oh, wait, they're both scamming me.
It just works.
Ah.
That's five.
Wait, how much is the back panel, though?
What is it?
What do I need?
Back panel.
Okay, how much is that?
How much is five?
1,730?
Okay, wait, let me double check.
We're 1,000.
Oh, wait, there you go.
Doesn't turn on.
All right, there.
I'll grab that from you.
That works for me.
Okay.
Ryan, thank you for the one gift that ship.
Thank you, thank you.
What I like is I don't have to clean it fully.
I can just be like, let's do a little sweep and it counts.
Tana, circuit board.
Is that all of it?
Circuit board.
And where the fuck is the, what's the antenna look like?
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
Let's just put all of it together for an oh nope the one
thing i need is i forgot the one thing i need to put
everything together is broken all right so i have parts for
this
but that cover is broken that's broken that's also broken
that's just dirty holy shit buy a new one there's no point
it's it's over
need corn okay another switch 2000 a thousand okay i'll buy
buy the thousand the spy knew it like nothing is salvageable
oh my god i'll use the last oh my last remaining
oh my god where's the 99 what's dirty back screen cartridge
switch okay one of these is bad
oh this is okay i was gonna say where can i see this where's
the other switch oh my god this is bad too all right
all right there it is
and just really plug all of these in for now back screen
usually low star one yeah that's what i thought until i
bought one from a one star and that shit was juiced up see
maybe he just got reviewed bomb you know you can't judge a
book by its cover he could have been reviewed bomb you don't
know that guys
okay what's this?
Oh, it's just a box.
Okay, now it's just cleaning tab.
I keep forgetting to take the battery off first.
Yeah, someone fucking put this in a vacuum cleaner or some
shit.
It's fucking disgusting.
Might as well just put this in the washing machine.
Put it on the washing machine.
This shit's disgusting.
Oh, no.
It's so hard to test this.
This is
Okay, this one.
Alright.
Gotta clean the fucking batteries instead of buying new
batteries.
It's okay.
It's an heirloom, apparently.
It's alright.
I won't judge.
I say as I judge.
Oh, I hear money.
I just heard money click in.
There we go.
Oh, I'm so close to getting...
Oh, 32!
There we go, baby!
Oh, where's the big ball?
Of course.
Of course it's out of stock.
Just when I want it.
I'll buy this.
Just when I need it the most.
It's out of stock.
Oh, please give me the...
I just need...
At least...
Just let me have it.
that brush.
Alright, I got my rent in.
What other stuff does he have for me?
Just when I need it the most, it's out of stock.
I need that.
Okay.
Alright, I think I actually have everything I need for the
phone.
I need, like, I legit just need that.
That one.
Wait, was it that?
Yeah.
It's all I needed.
Why do I have two of these?
I need to clean the display unit.
Oh, look at that.
My thicker brush.
That gotta take a loan for it.
I'm gonna add that in.
And
then...
Hit battery.
Oh my god, I'm like...
So in the zone now.
What do I need from this?
What do I need?
I needed one switch.
Did I not buy it?
Oh my god, I forgot to buy it.
I fucking forgot to buy it.
5,000.
Oh, it's even worth five.
Okay, what do I need?
I need one tiny switch.
Maybe?
No.
Oh my god, I'm fucking buying the tiny switch.
Fuck this.
What was it called?
What is this?
Atari.
Okay.
Uh, Atari.
Find that.
Fuck it.
Literally the only thing I have.
I'm not spending 5k.
Fuck that.
Just need one tiny switch.
This is a business here, sir.
I know.
someone's going to sell their i know someone's mom's not
going to know the worth of it and it's gonna sell it for
like 10 like five dollars i believe that's the risk i'm
willing to take
i'm willing to take that risk that some mom's gonna sell it
to me for five dollars Okay, clean, clean, clean, clean,
clean, clean, and repair.
Okay, there's one thing that I need to clean and repair.
Holy shit, is that mold?
Bro, it looks like, bro, your fucking controller looks like
has mold in it.
Might be over.
Bro, you might as well burn this.
it buddy
and nice what is it memory slot and all the buttons all
right
gonna put that in here first then oh no i did it again
hit action button that's a real gamer they guys been gaming
even with the mold
I'm missing the other.
There it is.
That's all of it.
Okay.
Yeah, I can do it behind.
Yeah.
I could do it looking at where it is.
All right, there we go.
Oh, that's the clean, right?
Okay, I should have enough for...
Oh, wait, I can clean!
Wait.
Should I buy a soldier in art?
Or...
The Kaiju N3 Ultrasonic Bath.
We're moving up in the world now, baby.
That's right.
Got the Kaiju whatever the fuck it is oh my god now we
cleaning here okay this is cleaning okay this is the one i
need repair okay
yeah put that in there yeah get that shit clean
you uh i think it was like three items right
That shit is broken.
I need screen, keyboard.
Oh, options button is broken too.
Wait, what is in there again?
I don't remember what's in there.
I don't think you're supposed to.
Hey, it's clean!
Okay, screen function option.
screen clean is clean function option button I have another
one I do thank god okay that's the only thing that's dirty
alright let's piece everything back together what do I break
oh it's a circuit board alright that's everything I can
piece together maybe I should put that I'm just gonna brush
that.
All right.
Maybe I should have just brushed that.
It might be a little faster.
Yeah, I got everything.
Nice.
It's all right.
He just has to put his thing in rice, and then it'll be
fine, guys.
Me and then repair.
Oh, that's 13k.
Okay, the brick is the one I need to repair.
Get that on your repair.
I'll fix that first, and then we'll clean this later.
I have anything for it.
I should.
Okay, throw that up.
Okay, back panel, battery.
All right.
Okay, one of the batteries are done.
Okay, this one.
Put that in there.
We'll put the control panel in there.
We'll put this in there.
Okay.
Holy shit, this shit is fried, fried.
Let's turn that on.
Oh my god, and nothing works.
Literally, your entire thing is fucked.
Kip.
Yoki, can you work on my PC?
I just need to put in like, they're like 3K worth of RAM for
free.
But totally pay you $100 to repair it.
Acer, thank you.
What a deal, guys.
But what a fucking deal.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, I got... I cleaned the battery.
I need another battery.
I need a screen.
And a motherboard.
Okay, just got everything.
Okay, all that's left is cleaning all of that shit.
Okay, motherboard and battery.
There we go.
Efficiency, guys.
Pure efficiency.
Okay, now I just gotta wait.
Efficiency, guys.
Pure efficiency.
All right, I'll clean this.
Almost forgot about that.
All right, it's clean.
It should be clean now.
Okay, we'll screw that in.
Oh.
All right, it's done.
Yay!
and then it cleaned this one too oops that in put that into
and this in oh and I can clean this myself by hand all right
and also this too see there you go okay maybe cleaning by
hand is a little faster there's It just...
Okay, fuck it.
I'm just going to use my parts here.
Peer efficiency, guys.
Where's the front panel?
Wait a minute.
There it is.
There we go.
Alright.
I gotta clean this too.
Trust in the rice.
Just like us Latinos, trust in Vapor Rudd for anything.
Heartbreak Vapor Rudd.
Broken Heart Vapor.
Oh, nobody put it.
Oh, wait.
Another damn.
Everybody's playing Sky Hill.
Put that in here.
That should go in here.
God, there's just so many screws.
It, like, fucks with me a lot.
Like, did I got out of them?
I can't tell.
There's so many.
Yeah.
Come on, clean that.
These need to be clean?
Okay, the control panel.
Which one's that?
Is this?
Where is it?
Where the fuck that?
Oh, it's over here.
Alright, everything's clean now.
I think the PPP is the hardest to repair for.
So far just because there's just so many parts too many
screws like it doesn't even matter the parts don't matter to
me It's just the fucking screws that fuck with me
Yeah, yeah Oh my god, where did these go?
Where did these go?
Oh, it goes here
It should go here Oh my god, it was upside down That's why.
That is because it was upside down.
So it's hard to see.
That's the only reason.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
Yay!
More than $100,000.
Yippee!
Okay, I should buy this soldering art.
I should buy that now.
Yay!
I don't know what to do with this, but yay!
Is that dirty?
100%.
Alright, time to put the battery in there.
Very nice.
Yeah, I need to clean that.
My repair service is booming!
It is!
It's doing so well.
I removed from this anything else to remove oh this time
there you oh i don't know i don't know what else i thought i
unscrewed everything oh now i just screwed everything
oh my god there was no point in me unscrewing everything
well i guess
Oh, this.
Okay, up here, some tiny knobs, and then big screw.
I should take more orders.
Clean, clean, clean, clean.
Where would...
Oh.
Can I take it?
Well, let me take...
Oh, wait.
Oh, these are the orders I already have.
I'm fucking...
I'm gaming, guys.
I'm fucking gaming.
I already...
These are the orders I'm actually doing right now.
Clean, clean, clean.
Okay, that definitely needs to be clean.
Wait, did I turn it on?
Is it cleaned?
Oh, my God.
It didn't turn out.
God damn, it didn't turn it on.
on it's fine and that should be everything okay
we just gotta wait for the other knobs yeah it's pretty it's
very relaxing I'm enjoying it a lot I'm like I'm glad the
Yakuza hasn't come over yet and shank me it's the little
things oh no not again.
Oh, there it is.
I thought I fucked up again.
Alright.
Take this order.
And the Tamagotchi.
Alright, we'll clean that.
I'm gonna use my little brush for this.
Alright.
I think God that Yakuza is a little busy right now, guys.
I just gotta wait for this now.
Yeah, it's pretty cute.
I can tell why this game took a...
I remember when I saw a trailer for this game, I was like,
oh, I have to play it.
I was like, I knew it was going to be a good game.
I didn't play the demo because I didn't want to spoil
myself, but I heard people talking about it.
That doesn't mean cleaning.
The fuck?
Why can't I unscrew this?
There it is.
All of this is...
Is this dirty?
this is dirty
everything else is clean right yeah it's just that part I'm
like in the rhythm right now for it
okay two more seconds whoop
there you go hello hello oh it's a fucking scrap After I
said, I'm in a fucking rhythm, guys.
I was like, why aren't you screwing on?
All right.
Nice.
That should be everything.
I did all my orders.
Well, I'm going to get my food.
It's been...
But now I'll get my food.
To reward myself.
All right.
I hate the screws.
The screws.
are so annoying though it's so tiny all right we had it i've
been living in the shop i've not gone home all
right let's see sleeping
love it when they don't give me a fork okay no god i'm a
fork
The shop is my home.
It is.
I'll see where the plot...
I want to know what to do with the soldering iron, and then
we'll call it here.
I might do more.
I don't know.
I don't know about playing this game more on stream.
I definitely will play it off stream.
I gotta think about it.
But I'm enjoying this game a lot.
It's just I don't know if it'll be, like, too repetitive,
but it's been relaxing for me.
I definitely can play this off stream.
No, it's the forest for the tiramisu, you guys, stupid.
You're going to want me to eat my tiramisu with my fucking
hands?
Yeah, it's a very comfy game.
It's a very good game.
I'm literally just waiting for the courier to come in and
take my stuff so I can see what the soldering iron comes in.
I just want to know what the soldering iron does.
Someone said it was like, someone checked and said it was
like a seven to eight hour game.
But it's like, I sort of like, but it's only if you progress
the plot, you know?
Did not end the day for seven days in the rope.
Akiba never sleep.
I didn't go home.
I've actually just been here.
I got the achievement like, you haven't gone home in seven
days.
Hi, Master.
I think I'm on the grind.
I think my network card burnt up Someone tried to change the
networking chip to hide the Mac address But didn't solder it
right That someone totally had no idea how to use the
soldering item You have one, right?
I'm counting you, Master.
Can you help?
I do want to do it quickly I'll let everyone know how
awesome Mastery you are I know a lot of people And there's
always new faces at the cafe Don't tell anyone that brought
you this, okay?
I know a lot of people Alright, let's check out from Harry
Alright, the soldering Iron tab wait, this is cleaning tab.
This is soldering iron tab.
I was promised soldering iron This is just cleaning tab
I can fix her guys or she can fix me whatever works.
I ain't picky Still not dirty yet
Oh, it's evil.
I don't tell me to sometimes
That's the only dirty part, right?
Oh, no, there's that.
Whoops.
Said there was, like, some soldering shit.
I literally was that.
Don't worry.
If you can solder this, I was, like, don't worry.
I got this.
There was no soldering whatsoever.
Oh, oh.
Soldering!
It's soldering!
How do I do it?
Oh my god.
Oh!
I soldered.
Yeah, I'm a professional solderer.
Yeah, I just did that.
Oh, and he's soldering?
Oh, whoops, I washed a circuit board by accident.
My bad.
It did not need to be cleaned.
Oh, whoops.
Made a little oopsie there.
Alright.
Sorry for bothering you.
My console seems to have broken.
Sorry for distracting you from your port and work.
The power went out recently.
I lost all my progress and adventure.
That game has no say's and no cheat codes.
Plus, when the power came back on, the console stopped,
started smoking.
I've been having so much trouble with electricity lately.
Oh my gosh, who could have done such a thing?
Oh, I also was having power flickers.
Very, I don't know why that happened too.
Gotta get that guy.
I'll look online to see what it might be.
I'll let you know if I find anything.
Uh.
Alright, we'll call it here.
I saw what soldering does.
Thanks for fixing it, Master.
I'm glad I didn't have to call off the deal.
I used to have some extra cash on top of my stipend.
By the way, do you get accepted into repair master
competition yet?
Our deal's still on, you know?
I would, no, we, no, I like her.
Both of us can really use some new customers, right?
I was at home yesterday practicing sobering at a new
apartment that I'm found.
And then it was so weird.
The light started flickering and even went out completely at
one point.
I thought it was something I did.
It's like that all over Akiba.
Plus, this cop has started stopping by the cafe all the time
he thinks i won't recognize him in civilian clothes um just
sits there and sits coffee for hours he has goman with him
and it's probably recording people's conversation why else
would he be there it makes me so why are you so nervous
you're an innocent you're innocent why is she so nervous
guys she's so innocent she oh it's a tip jar
I need to grab that before I go.
Oh my god.
All right, we'll call it here.
That was fun, though.
I had a lot of fun.
I'm going to main menu just in case.
But that was so fun.
I don't know if I'm going to play another part of this on
stream.
I'll think about it.
But I've been having a really fun time.
It's very relaxing, honestly.
It's a very relaxing game.
Very chill.
And I've been...
I get like so like I get like locked zoned in into it from
the repairing and the cleaning it's very comfy game and I've
been enjoying it a lot but yeah highly recommend checking it
out if you guys like these types of games it's very relaxing
and comfy to play uh anyway guys uh tomorrow there'll be two
streams tomorrow I'm not putting a schedule for this this
week because like I said there's just like three days and I
was just like oh yeah it's just three days but tomorrow 12
30 there'll be a stream called horse magnifier and then 6 p
.m.
well i'll have the waiting room up later today because i
have the thumbnails already so 6 p.m will be animal hospital
the roblox game and then 12 30 will be horse magnifier and
then saturday i'll have a stream at 5 p.m um hey guys as
always everybody stay hydrated post-check get up and around
to get that blood flowing and if you sell for me head to bed
because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody
thanks Thanks for having me out.
I had a great time.
It was very comfy.
Bye, everybody.
Bye.